this is Jocko podcast number 86 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening and it
has been a little while since we got
down to some QA sure and on top of that
on the social media I have not been as
responsive as I normally am I've had to
prioritize and execute a bunch of other
things things like muster things like
books that are due things like that so
and a bunch of travel and a bunch of
work with echelon front etc etc so but I
do get the questions I read the
questions I read it I read if you post
something and you tag me in it on
Twitter or you put a comment on
Instagram I read it a hundred percent
yeah I read it
but lately and normally I would like
everything that I see sure I would like
just just so you know hey that's all
right I got you yeah I'm here
I heard you but lately I have anything
to do that Dan so I've just been I read
it move read it move free to move but if
there's a good question comes up I copy
it I pasted I put it in the in a
question Bank
and then when we get to do QA we answer
the questions that I think either they
get asked a bunch you know so I've seen
a question four or five times that title
question yeah or just a unique question
that I think a lot of people can benefit
from and that's where we end up with so
today QA and let's rock and roll
first quest I do want to add that on
Twitter also seed also you know you say
you like everything you know yeah
certain things sometimes they don't
necessarily warrant like you liking them
they require an answer you know like you
can't like so like let's say phone has
this like really trying time or
something and they say something or
whatever and it's a question like hey
how do I get through this you can't just
like it and move on okay I can do that
so what I do in those situations is
I like it I copy the question and I put
it in the question though okay so you're
like is my likeness various meanings my
life does not mean like yeah yeah my
like means we seve gotcha yes yeah
excited and and it is a heart which I
vehemently disapprove of and disagree
risk you know like hearts no no blood no
no hearts are closed world tonight yes
sir so well I do too it's my way of
saying I read it but and what I'm saying
is it's saying that I'm read it I'm
telling you that right at this the past
like week I've read everything I always
read everything but I haven't even like
them because I haven't had time to start
liking them saying yes because if I like
it that tells me that I've gone through
it and if I had to pull something from
it it's how I keep track of what I've
read in whatever not just what I've read
it's how I keep track of what I have
extracted pertinent information from
yeah I might have to start doing the
opposite only like something if I want
to go back to it oh yeah like a bookmark
yeah maybe I'll start doing that yeah
but anyways if you're out there I'm
reading your messages your tweets your
posts right I'd appreciate it it's all
good feedback it's awesome yeah but
sometimes you get your your in the
initial post will sing and maybe I'm in
there maybe some other people and then
other people chime in then it starts to
morph into this conversation between two
other yeah you can't really like those
necessary and you can usually do but
just to keep track of where I am just
like like oh yes I'd like market stuff
it work so this you talking right now is
just one big mass like yes saying hey
guys already here it is you know you're
less if I'd like to like you all all
right or not I like you all cuz some of
your comments are don't like yeah I
still like them though yeah verb like
yeah yeah I like a press like even
though you said something I don't agree
with so I still like my fact that you
expressed yourself no
and so even if I hate what you said you
still get a little heart yeah there you
go
they should have one that's an eye like
a picture of an hi like I've seen this
that's what it means i all right
recognized eyeball I saw this I saw this
I saw this and then you could say like
and you should have a thumbs down
dislike yeah like on YouTube yeah yeah
either way there you go
all right first question hey joko I'm a
35 year old and have a physically
demanding job I've been a drywall ER for
about 14 years
work about eight to ten hours a day when
it comes to working out I'm finding it
really hard to maintain discipline to
continue as it seemed as it seems I
burnout I also have two boys under the
age of four
so I sleep like you do I can regulate
then yeah I'm wondering if I'm just
being a pussy and need to push through
the burnout or take a different approach
to working out when I burn out my body
just feels weird as well as my head I
tend to get depressed and find it hard
to even go to work just throwing this
out there for maybe some tips to get
over this so I can stay focused and
consistent Thanks
cool okay so hanging drywall have you
ever hung drywall before no yes no say
yes okay a bit what answer me I've been
in a dry wall hanging scenario scenario
yes but I didn't do the hanging of the
drywall kya that does not qualify well I
saw it done before bro you do not get
called I did her hair done if you've
seen it being done I appreciate what
you're trying to say but that doesn't
work bang drywall is hard work yes sir
it uses a bunch of different muscles
into your body
and of course when you get better at it
because I'm not good at it when I when I
hung dry when I hang drywall if I'm
doing a project I'm not good at it you
see someone that's good at like this guy
that's been hanging drywall for 14 years
he's a master yeah he's he's holding one
hand slap and nails him he's your
drywall screw he's on stilts guys work
on stilts reversing that before no no so
good drywallers they're on stilts
because they don't they're just boom
slapping it up there so but it's hard
you're doing you're basically doing a
clean I need a pull the the drywall up
you're pushing it up you're using your
grip strength on the drywall then you're
doing overhead presses because you
drywall ceilings all times yes so and
it's 8 to 10 hours plus not to mention
you're you're bending down picking stuff
up all day so it's 8 to 10 hours of
squats cleans and overhead presses with
grip work so you're doing that 8 to 10
hours a day so you're getting good
physical work throughout the day now
look man if you're that drained then
first of all let's check the diet let's
make sure that we're not on the jobsite
and the donut truck arrives and you're
you're going belly up to the donut truck
in with a monster for Monster energy
drinks like to keep you going today
that's going to hurt you so check the
diet it's the good thing is check the
diet and then if you have to just bring
your food don't let you know your bro
that's going to run down to Mickey D's
to grab lunch because you didn't pack
anything that's going to jack you up so
all that stuff will make you feel weak
and out of sorts and all bad that being
said still you're working hard all day
you're doing hard physical labor all day
you also I mean you can see construction
workers or drywall is you can see people
that are do that hard labor all day and
they don't look like they're in shape
right there maybe they're fat maybe
they're just they don't look like
they're in shape well that's because
their diet sucks generally they're
coming home and they're getting on their
their 12-pack of beer and pizza
so get your diet make sure your dad's
good to go and then what I would do is
and I've worked construction before and
will even make projects on my house
where I'm working all day long
remodeling pulling down drywall putting
up drywall demo in rooms whatever uh I
still do work out now what you're going
to do though is do something that is
going to complement what you've done
during the day so you're getting some
pretty good strength of work at this
point
you're getting you can clean your grip
work you're doing all this this hard
work all throughout the day so maybe
what you need to do is do some more
cardiovascular at night or maybe it's
just like a really good stretching
routine because you got your strength
and you got your cardio do during the
day like if I think about how much I
sweat when I'm working on a house
project my house I'm going to full
athletic sweat so that means I'm working
hard mmm
so find what can you do that's going to
complement the the conditioning that
you're getting from your actual labor
and maybe in your case it might just be
like straight up mobility it might be
straight up mobility like hey you're
just doing some good stretching you're
doing some mobility WOD
that's mobility workout of the day you
can go that website they got really good
stuff on there to loosen up and make
sure you're staying limber because
another thing you find with construction
guys is they end up with some you know
with a bad back with a bad they get you
know tendinitis from swinging a hammer
all day or holding do it so you can get
those kind of use overuse injuries and
yeah so I would look at what you can do
that's going to complement that also
maybe you feel like you maybe just need
to do some heavy lifting because you
lifting something little all day no
leave you lift and drywall all day so
you're getting some good endurance
muscular endurance but maybe just come
home and do do a couple sets of heavy
deadlifts or a couple sets of heavy
squats and it the other thing here is
like when we're on deployment when I was
back in the in when I was in the
military when we were on the planet we
wouldn't be doing workouts that are
going to give you the four days of blade
onset muscular soreness right you're not
gonna burn Dockers you're not gonna put
you in the pain locker and yeah we're
hey I did squats yesterday oh echo just
got shot I can't help but retire selling
you sword broken someone grab Beco
because my legs are super sore my quads
are hurting from front squats yesterday
yeah yeah so that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about doing some
something that's heavy but it's quick
and you're not you know you're not going
crazy and doing so many sets that you're
going to build up all kind of lactic
acid make your legs all sore so maybe
it's something that but I would say
explore all that look what you can find
that's going to make you that's going to
compliment you what you do work and
so you could look some jujitsu you know
look at some jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu
although at first it's a crazy muscular
workout a full body workout like you've
never had before
yeah because you're resisting every part
of your movement and you'll be sore in
your entire body but then as you get
better at it you can relax more that
takes like a year year and a half maybe
even two years before you can really
start to relax the thing that's cool
about that for you is you got two kids
under the age of four so maybe in two or
three years they're ready to start
training - now you got something to
share with them a little bit in
jiu-jitsu
so yeah don't kill yourself find
something that complements your work and
if that's just stretching then just
stretch yeah and maybe you know nice do
it uh when I was a team - team can we
see we used to run all the time it was
every day it was like Oh Monday PT in a
run
Tuesday swim in a run Wednesday obstacle
course and the run run yeah Thursday I
forget what it was and then Friday was a
long run it was like a 12 mile run or 10
mile run on Fridays so what I would do
is I would get done with work on Friday
or get done with a PT on Friday and
usually would be like half half day
frogman Friday
sure probably I'm try to get some
pre-war no war going on that's what you
do on Friday afternoon in the dreams
you're gonna go you know get after with
your boys in the bar on the bar sir yeah
frogmen phrenic frogman Friday VN
frogman Friday kind of in a way once
September 11th happened so this is pre
September 11th fireman Fridays so we get
done with work and you know noon and I
would Friday go down and hit my squats
and then so Friday I'd heal up Saturday
and Sunday back to work on Sunday ready
to rock and roll yeah so maybe you hit
just do a good workout on Friday
yeah good hard work out on Friday heal
up over the weekend you're feeling good
Monday back in the game but yeah hard
labor
yeah requires something a little bit
different yeah then those of you that
are sitting at a desk looking at a
computer screen like echo Charles yes
sir yeah you can do a different kind of
workout when you do that all day for
sure
you mentioned the diet I would say with
99% certainty I would say I don't know
everybody right I understand that 99%
certainty that if you have a good diet
not even a immaculate that a good diet
and you're working drywall construction
moving her as you know I used to be a
mover for a little bit yeah
if you have a good diet I mean you
watched moving because apparently your
mind that qualifies for you know it's
total victory yeah well just anyway oh
yeah I know you were an actual yeah but
good correct I wasn't the best mover I
was one of them anyway that's that's
another thing anyway if you have a good
diet and you're doing this kind of work
that is your workout essentially and
it's a long one it's probably a harder
workout than most people's normal
workout you do and that's the thing
you're so right because when you're
working 810 hours a day there's a lot of
work to be done so your lunch break is
like dang this is I'm gonna go to get
some delicious you know food truck right
here or this you know McDonald or
wherever wherever it's not you know you
but you get a good diet with this kind
of stuff you eventually have a great
workout along with a good diet you're
going to get results just that yeah and
in a way you won't even really have to
do these supplemental workouts unless
you have different goals so if you're
like okay I'm just going to do my work
I'm have a good diet and then I stretch
afterwards which is such a good idea
when you're called there's a motion all
day stretch you know get all that spread
you'll be way better you'll feel way
better to him you'll be surprised how
much easier the work becomes yeah and
also maybe there's like I said you need
to look for what complements it yeah so
with drywall I don't I don't know you
know it's probably not dead lifting
because you're less lifting stuff all
day but maybe it's just like some hard
core like AB core strength that you're
going to work your you know and that's
going to strengthen your lower back it's
going to offset all the pressure that
you put on your back all day so maybe
it's that maybe it's you know pull-ups
because you're not really pulling
yourself up yeah so so maybe you're
doing two workouts maybe you're doing
like one workout on Fridays you're doing
abs and pull-ups yeah
and then during the week you're doing a
20 minute stretch session yeah to really
make sure your hips are opened up right
sure
of course like them guys from Ted's plan
as you shit yeah yeah gotta be flexible
they're flexible that's that you have to
be you have to be able to do Lotus to
get your black belt from Eddie Bravo
there you go I can't do the Lotus I
can't get my black belt from Eddie Bravo
no no no you can't no sorry bro I should
be able to do that at some point it
depends on what you mean by should but
yeah I'm cool do the Lotus and work on
that and you know report back
but yeah the diet thing I think the diet
thing that's going to be 75 if not more
per se or people help you they say you
don't sleep enough and how could how do
you don't see don't eat crap you don't
use as much sleep yeah check that out
give that one a try yeah and listen
let's face it there's people can be
different with these requirements you're
not really you know like if I said hey
Jocko you're in prison for one or
whatever and you have eight hours of
sleep
ya know week for eight hours we judge
the other know how to light on the ship
multiple times free ship four
deployments as a seal and when you're a
seal on a ship you have no job you're
like the guys that are the guys that are
in the regular Navy that are driving the
ship and maintaining the ship and
steering the ship and all that they have
a job
we have no job yeah and so what we we
could either sleep eat or lift and
that's a waste threat you'll stood for
three feet and lift but some guys would
sleep a lot yeah I wouldn't sleep a lot
really it's a guy that had looks sleep
disorders there was a guy that slept for
like twenty nine hours but they need to
wake up and stay awake for 32 hours and
then he go back to bed yeah it was kind
of weird really cut his circadian rhythm
as well yeah and then that happens to on
a ship because you can stay inside the
ship with no Sun for four F you want to
that's Sam we used to we used to go out
as much as we could on the deck of the
ship yeah get a suntan
no do pt sure that too but yeah I think
you um yeah you sleep different and from
a tower
actually I've done this thing where I
got used to only getting like six six
and a half and it it started to work
like I said you know I didn't like this
thing I tried to go back to actually I
only get six maybe seven though anyway
because the kids think anyway the diet I
think will I for real thing I believe
this there'll be effect 75% or more
solution to the whole problem the diet
clean up your diet is good
bring your lunch yeah stay away from the
Mickey D's yeah still with salsa but
again man that's that is hard though
consider it I mean yes yeah it's hard to
but you retired it's a cycle that you
start going down yeah because you
retired when you got home so you didn't
make any food for the next day so that
means you brought something crappy or
you bought fast food and now you ate the
fast food which makes you feel bad which
means a home your tires which means you
don't make lunch for the next day which
means your own ass bad cycle yeah and
that's not to mention the pleasure part
of it because again is hard work I need
some relief from this hard work work on
my lunch break
bringing like cool um dark chocolate
yeah maybe
right like bring some chocolate milk
yeah Jake it tastes good and it's good
for you well are you believe we'll say
arguably it's not as bad for you as a
mountain Dew yeah or a pizza by the
slice from the don't drop the food truck
yeah and that's usually what it is man
take from me I know all right cool next
question I the way that was one question
we're 20 minutes deep alright okay men
I'm gonna get to the bottom of your
cooking I think that'll help though I
think so because look if you if let's
say if you think oh yeah maybe I'll
change my diet but you know what okay
I'll maybe I will maybe I'll just kind
of focus on the workout part of it yeah
you can Batman one time I was like I
didn't do any cardio I just kind of
lifted and whatever my diet was not all
that and sure I was being strong I went
to the doctor they said your your
cholesterol thing you know some stuff on
the inside I was super unhealthy he was
like you're unhealthy come on big and
strong I was like wait sir but I can
bench a lot like bro that doesn't matter
so you can hang drywall all day all day
and dang that's some good endurance if
you can do that all day every day for 14
years by the way and be like oh
unhealthy because you ate wrong it'll
Jam you up that bad clean up to die
yes good news clam the diet that's the
whole situation
next question where do you how do you
install pride back into an individual
and ultimately a battalion I'm on my
seventh seventeenth year serving in the
British Army I've been in my role for
about a decade and I'm about to move on
to a different job recently I've came
out of my platoon bubble and noticed
there are numerous issues I've
identified and I'm looking to help my
COC in fixing it all right so you aren't
still pride back into the kalian into a
unit into an individual in my opinion
pride comes from hard work mm-hmm pride
comes from discipline pride comes from
performance and pride comes from winning
and how do you win you win from hard
work you win from discipline so that's
the cycle you work hard you stay
disciplined that makes you start to
perform that makes you start to win when
you start to win you get pride and of
course there's a dichotomy there too
because you can work your guys too hard
right you can do that so you have to
balance it then it's funny actually life
was talk about this I think it was uh we
were with a company and he was saying
when we formed up task unit bruiser we
worked hard we worked a lot harder the
normal task units worked
we stayed later at work we came in
earlier and you know he was saying hey
when we first the first like month we
were together and and Jacko's got
everyone coming in early and all this
stuff and people are grumbling about it
and why do we got to do this extra stuff
then these days I gathers people are
growing about but then once we started
going through training in our
performance was above our peers then all
of a sudden it turned from grumbling to
like Pride yeah so that's being then the
guys they stopped complaining and they
start bragging yeah because you know
what we're to you bruiser you know
of course you're not at work because
your ears asking is weak we are strong
you are weak get away from us we don't
wanna be associated with you so you
start getting that which is you know
pride yeah so I think that's what you
got to do you got to instill the hard
work the discipline in your team it'll
hurt a little bit at first you got to
make sure you don't go overboard with it
and that'll get you what you want if you
need further references on that read a
book called steal my soldiers hearts by
colonel david hackworth or read about
faced by colonel david hackworth he
talks about this that he cakes these
cakes battalion is the kind of vietnam
with no pride and turns them into people
with a ton of pride how did he do it
make some more card makes him have
discipline and then they take pride in
what they're doing
lead by example
yes yeah only and hackworth he doesn't
change everything at once he's in come
in and just go crazy
he starts changing important small
things couple of day huh i think
literally he says two a day it changed
two things a day yeah it's good but he
did start off with a big thing if you
remember this he checked in this
battalion guys have radios guys have
guitars guys have little bars set up
they got all this crap he goes eh
everything that you can't fit in a
rucksack tomorrow morning in the middle
of the compound here and we're getting
rid of it
that was a big wake-up call for everyone
but it was a it was a wake-up call and
also it was why are we doing this or
we're doing this so that we can move
when we move we won't get hit at night
we'll get hit at night we won't lose
anybody so good stuff
make sense next question sorry for the
English I'm French
that's a disclaimer how can a man that
has not grown up with the confidence and
trusting male role models and mentors
sort of anti Uncle Jake person's only
intellectual I'm saying this without
district or disrespect to these people
how can they become a confident man and
develop the necessary man skills quote
unquote
okay it's interesting you can say man
skills in quotes and I think we pretty
much know what that means right yes like
100 sentience so so how do you do that
you don't have any positive role model
around you that's like an uncle Jake
which by the way most people don't have
an Uncle Jake Yeah right that's not
normal to have uncle Jake most people
you got what you got and in this case
he's saying he's got like the
intellectuals so you know my parents
were college professors and they don't
have any of these skills and they sit
around and talk about philosophy right
now I ended up I can talk about
philosophy well but I can't fix my car
yeah or I can't defend myself yeah in a
combat scenario in the streets and so
what are you gonna do okay this is real
simple
go do things go do things lift start
lifting weights learn how to deadlift
learn how to squat that's a best part
about being a man right sure physically
stir yeah physically strong learn some
jujitsu
I recommend that probably could have
guessed that one yeah learning how to
fight learning how to defend yourself I
just got asked this the other day
kid came up to me he's like what should
I do if I get intimidated by the people
and I or I don't know how to react when
people like get in my face I said do you
change it no start training in jiu-jitsu
mmm-hmm but then what I'm gonna fight
everyone no no you don't have to cuz you
already know you can beat them up right
now would say attack you yeah you can be
them up but if they are just getting in
your face and trying to Punk you and you
look at them and go hey if you want to
do this let's do this but I don't care
yeah I know you can come to my gym I'll
talk you out train some jiu-jitsu so we
got that one run hike sprint
climb build things start building things
rewire things do some plumbing
these things are not they're not
impossible to do now it's going to take
you longer right like I've rewired my
parts of my house
I've replumbed parts of my house we've
done all the plumbing and parts of my
house now if you watch a skilled
electrician do what I'm doing it would
literally take him 1/8 of the time maybe
1/4 of the time because or like the
drywall over you're talking about
earlier a good drywaller they are like
masters a good electrician masters a
good plumber they're smooth me it's
going to take a while sure so but but
what I'm saying it is not impossible
yeah it's not impossible to do and it'll
take you more time but you're learning
how to do it and that gives you was that
give you it gives you the self-reliance
hey I can fix my electrical outlet if I
need to yeah so those are good things
work on your car change your oil
whatever do those things and and again
those things like I so I took
electricity class in high school sure
where we learned how to wire rooms and
everything does that what it's called
elec it was called electricity class
right um I took electricity with Scotty
was the teacher's name sure wait you
called him Scott everyone called him
Scott it he was an older guy his name
was Scotty we all call him Scotty so
Scotty but we we learned how to walk
wire houses and all that well I didn't
remember any of that when I was now 20
years later or 15 years later I'm
rewiring my kitchen where I which I
ripped out of my house okay so what did
I do you know what I did
went down to Home Depot mmm I bought a
book called electrical wiring and I read
through it and I'd followed the
directions
same thing with plumbing yeah go down by
a book called how to do plumbing and you
do it and it and the good thing about
this stuff is it's very satisfying to do
that kind of work yeah it's very
satisfying to do it and you can over
engineer things you make things super
solid in your own house
yes secure if super yeah you can kind of
go the extra distance because it's your
own
in house so that's cool so those are all
physical things and some kind of
knowledge things that you can start
working on what the hardest thing to
overcome here is like a level of
embarrassment
yeah right Holika like I don't know
anything about wiring oh yeah yeah you
know I don't know I'm embarrassed to say
I don't know anything about wiring yeah
and so people don't want to say anything
so they'd rather just say hey let's get
an electrician in here to figure this
one out yeah or Hale is good yeah so
they're too embarrassed but if you have
time do it yourself yeah and don't be
embarrassed about be like I am where I'm
rewiring my kitchen to have no idea what
I'm doing
yeah give me this book yeah what I need
to get Oh give me some tools it's good
to have good tools yeah also so that's
that's like I said those are things that
you can do you know um
learn to shoot you know learn to shoot
that's a good good skill to have also
read write read about history read about
survival read about the world read about
human beings under duress read read
books good books about good stuff not
challenges it's and then it's just like
mark and we're the warrior kid he
doesn't know his times tables he has to
learn them you have to go learn all this
stuff and talk about you have to go
learn and with with time your confidence
is going to grow and from humility
you'll grow into being more confident
now you also say don't have any mentors
or role models around you that's okay
because those mentally mentors and role
models are in books and you can find
them I just talked about david hackworth
good mentored a half imagine you can
have a guy a guy wrote you a 1000 page
book on how to lead and it's for you
that's pretty awesome
beyond band of brothers by dick winners
guess what here's a guy that was the in
charge of the band of brothers in
Normandy and
he wrote a book for you to learn how to
lead so those are some examples and like
I said most of the books that we've
covered on this bar many of the books
that we cover on this podcast and give
you a mentor better than anyone could
possibly hope for
yeah so you can get it there but and we
mostly cover war books but there's books
about all kinds of people that can be
virtual mentors so read study do do
that's my advice on that one yeah that
physically strong thing is a in my
opinion a big deal because especially
what with um you know intellectual types
in that kind of environment since that's
not really a priority a lot of the time
you can't you know how like you're not
into something so you kind of shun it
and yeah y'all got adults you know like
so and I've seen this on nothing all the
time but you know sometimes the in I
don't like takedown so I'm not going to
do it yeah and then you think of all the
reasons why you don't need to do it and
how guys focused you know or whatever so
in an intellectual circle we'll see our
little circles sometimes you'd be like
oh yeah those meatheads or whatever you
know they just don't shun it or you
something about that issue
ah yeah yeah me know I don't exactly
yeah but they'll do that and then
there'll be these physically frail
people but since they they're in their
mind smarter than everyone I feel like
they have the one up in there kind of
there's an element of satisfaction there
yeah but at the end of the day you're
physically weak there comes down yeah
and I think most of the time I think I
don't know but it seems like most of the
time they'll have these feelings like
this guy asked right here like yeah man
how can I develop because I feel it yeah
yeah unless they just want to be in
denial right that's what exactly I'm bad
and also feel and by the way the same
thing happens in Reverse right yeah guys
just a meathead he shuns and and
disrespects or disregards the
intellectual side of man and that is
that is equally as bad because they're
not they don't know what's going on
they're not knowledgeable they're not
learning they don't understand the world
in a clear way so find the balance
between those two things yeah yeah
what's great is those things are not
mutually exclusive like you don't have
to just be a meathead or just have to be
a bookworm right you can do both
there's plenty of time in the day to do
both be a smart ass guy with a big
deadlift good thing I'm trying to be
that guy yeah yeah not there yet but I'm
not working on it yeah and then that one
level up which is the jujitsu part of it
you didn't think to a thing about judo
jujitsu combines the intellectual piece
with the physical yeah and in a way you
can cut them I wouldn't I'm not
recommending this at all in fact I'm
against this but this is the nature of
jujitsu you don't have to be that like
you don't have to have a big deadlift to
dominate in Judas or you don't have to
do any of that so you can essentially
overcome the physical part of it even
though just physical but it's a you
don't have to use you know overcome a
little part of it for it to a point yeah
yeah in everyday life I mean you you're
trying to you're trying to be the cell
guy like if someone's better than you at
jiu-jitsu training room it really
bothers you are you talking about
everyone or yes I love it you jock
doesn't bother me
well let's say it motivate I don't know
you wait like it doesn't bother me right
right right I mean like for instance I
trained with Dean Lester all the time
yeah he's better at me in jujitsu right
I everyday want to train with him right
so it doesn't bother ya it's not bother
but like what enough compels you like
involves like you know maybe does like I
hate it at the end of 90 depends on what
you mean by mother I hate it I do I hate
it and I love it and I were just was
joking about the other because we got a
little scrap yesterday yeah you know
kind of and the training and all of a
sudden things got escalated man and
there was some shouting going on and
shouting shouting yeah yeah yeah no he
was saying what he says and I was saying
what I say and but we had a you know we
had a mutual truce at the end we I think
he didn't really want any more I didn't
really want any more so we just kind of
just let's laugh you call it good
because you're rolling the dice when I'm
rolling with Dean there's a dice roll
happening because if he ends up in a
good position on me just gonna be paid
they're gonna be paid yes
if I end up a good position on him
there's gonna be pain so I think both of
us we got away a little bit of them
scathed neither one of us got a really
good position and we I got back up to my
feet and I and then we both kind of just
had a mutual agreement an unspoken
agreement yeah we were done for the day
yeah yeah yeah that happens but the
point there being is in almost like in
this weird way you know how like
intellectually you can excel so you can
kind of find it justifiable to avoid the
physical part of it
it's almost like you could almost say
the same thing about jujitsu you could
still be effective in defend yourself
without be physically strong necessarily
but but my point is that there's a
limitation to that oh yeah ultimately
you you can be you can be unbelievable
at jujitsu but if you're really really
weak and you go against someone that's
really good at jujitsu but they're a
hell of a lot stronger than you yeah
you're gonna have some issues right
right yeah and all that goes for
everything you gotta be both
yeah I ideally and that's ultimately the
main point is just like how
intellectually you can be you know a
black belt and you can sort in a way get
away with not necessarily being oh and
vice versa and then jujitsu like that
third element you can sort of get away
with that being super strong but still
be effective and just you know I mean so
yeah ideally just like a war in the
middle yeah get that balance but being
able to defend yourself is a whole
nother thing than being physically
strong and you know seems obvious but
when you go through life I think it's
not because you get these like big jacks
guys and it's like no one wants to mess
with him well bro this medium to small
guy who knows jujitsu or knows you know
for real fighting stuff is way more of a
I was like dangerous but yeah ultimately
way more dangerous than this big jack
guy who can lift a lot for sure so it's
that third element that are kind of like
weird when you roll with somebody that's
super jacked and they don't know jujitsu
yes and it's amazing well it is it's
like amazing
yeah you just think yourself how is this
happening yeah this is the magical power
yeah because you look at a big jack guy
your human instincts tell you look out
yeah he's gonna fat person is stronger
than you
you know watch out but when you know
jiu-jitsu yeah you know and eventually
you realize you don't even have that
anymore
yeah you know everyone you're looking at
thinking well you don't have well you
don't have no caffeine that is Amir
yeah instinctive fear although you're
still you you you know my first thought
when I look at someone's like do they
train or not yeah do they train or not
if they train we we may have issues this
could be a problem if they don't train
no factor yeah no train no factor yeah
if they train may have a factor that's
why I got to work out hard sorry every
strong yeah yeah you know you know cuz
they might be coming to take my lunch
money maybe right over Knox don't want
that how's this last night literally
last night she didn't rain last night I
did not train last fall there were a
real world picture so you know the five
gallon jugs of water you know those damn
you put in a water cooler or whatever so
this like a little refilling thing that
I went to lay it was like next type of
story people know there's another one
last night a so hazardous duty I know
water refilling joke
yeah I'm okay I imagine I do that okay
last night when I was doing that I was
refilling the jug you know I go in sir
I'm coming out walking to my truck to
get the empty jugs to go to the little
thing as I'm walking to my truck a car
pulls up right next to the water filling
thing mm-hmm
there's a what's called a red box you
know what that it's a DVD rental thing
yeah so carpals up a kid maybe 12 years
old jumps out of the car he starts like
a yoke do it no normal kid whatever and
from in the car this thing male probably
his dad some maybe step that really and
immediately the dead start yelling at
him like just put it in the sink and
just to the point where I thought it was
kind of joking where cuz all joking my
daughter like that were kind of like
hell you'll do sometimes do yeah some
people get it but in it sounded like a
joke but I was like wow this guy's
serious and the kid is like you could
tell he was kind of used to it feels
like I am I'm doing I'm trying you know
whatever whatever and second the whole
parking lot could hear and there's at
nighttime
secure setting so I'm off to my truck on
my bro if I get to this place and this
guy's still there not even yelling there
I'm gonna have to say something not be a
dick not be like hey don't talk like
that I'm going to try to solve this
problem
be like it is kidding you know whatever
I had this little thing before I knew
digits or anything I thought I wouldn't
mess with it I would even beam like big
or whatever in strong I would have been
like ah man that's not ever going back I
don't going on there yeah you know but
man I was like man I'm going to do so I
grabbed a big big left so I didn't get
the opportunity but I'm just saying
these are things that can happen on
varying levels every day yeah and if
your intellectual tech not and I'm not
saying if you're an intellectual but if
you don't have these elements of gonna
be skill or knowledge or whatever like
those things mess with you you know yeah
I can't yeah when I did I use your tool
and when I figured out what you did you
was when Master Chief Steve Bailey
choked me that he was he was an old man
at the time probably three years younger
than I am and I wasn't thinking myself
this how this guy just do this to me
doesn't sane that simply insane I need
to learn whatever he knows teach to me
whatever you know because I don't want
to feel that way ever right and then
your training it like let's say you
trained for five years for five years
your training not against people who
don't know you're trained against before
who know you know dangerous people who
do know like how to defend your shit and
then you go in the real world
yeah you have this guy has no idea how
much control you have over and you
didn't touch it there I see yeah that's
totally again this this whole thing
where I mean you're and that your thing
about um some guy was the guy was his
problem was like when people get in his
face or whatever his problem wasn't
getting beat up it was when people get
in your face and how you react in that
right feeling right off right that
feeling gone yeah because you're right
your hump isn't right because he said he
wasn't scared of fighting he was saying
like I might get in trouble he was he
didn't like how he felt right felt like
he should do something and he felt like
a limp basically when you know that you
can destroy someone then it doesn't
matter you just think they're an idiot
yeah you beat them you get the strength
and the skills and you actually beat
them on an intellectual level oh so it's
like a day
no gravitational done now all right yeah
yeah if you think it's those three
intellectual psychological whatever
mental physical and skill wise defending
yourself that's tough it's a three right
there
good stuff now it's just just how hard
you want to hit it really you wanna hit
a dog I think so too
you know is very beneficial to hit it
all right next question
chuckle should someone always be
detached okay straightforward question
the answer is no someone shouldn't
always be detached but otherwise you
aren't enjoying anything in your life so
don't always be attached detached no but
at the same time that being said you
should be aware all the time if you are
getting sucked into the emotional vortex
right you've got to be aware of that
once you have that awareness you don't
need to be attached all the time at all
you can I'm not always detached at all
but but I've got clear warning signs
when things start going sideways and I
start going down some vortex I know
immediately I just did that so it's
really easy it's but it's it does take
practice and eventually you realize that
you know when you're feeling overwhelmed
when you're feeling emotional and you're
feeling angry or you're feeling
frustrated when you start feeling those
things and you've sent them really
quickly and you recognize them you just
attach boom you're done yeah so that's
what you got to do start recognizing
those red flags so that you can enjoy
the good things and when something
starts getting crazy you can detach yes
looks like a overall skill of being able
to control when to detach and when you
don't have to being able to identify
yeah when you need to detach then being
able to detach then you're good
yes looks like it's a matter of being
capable of making an accurate beneficial
choice yeah switch the identification is
the hard part yes he's old
what happens to people when they talk to
me is they go the after the fact they
realized I lost my temper and I did this
yeah okay
you didn't detach anytime and that's why
you ended up there yeah so or I said
some things to my you know my
ex-girlfriend that I shouldn't have said
because I got too emotional exactly
you didn't attach and talk yeah you got
crazy and emotional so the skill that
you're missing is identifying when
you're starting to get too emotional
whatever that emotion might be once you
identify boom detach yeah kinda like
control then you can take a joke yes and
make tactical moves yeah
not emotional that's ultimately the art
you know meaning the move you know how
like jujitsu guys if they never take no
you know what the moves when you're
emotionally detach the moves actually
aren't that hard they're actually
usually pretty obvious
yeah like your beer in a fight with your
girlfriend and and you're starting to go
down the wrong lane as soon as you did
that you go oh I know what I need to do
yeah I should say I'm sorry and tell her
that we can go the restaurant that she
wants to go to or whatever you know to
me the moves are not actually that hard
yeah we never make good moves when we're
being emotional right instead we just go
no I don't want to go to that restaurant
we went there three external and I don't
care if I said that to you you reserved
me to say that to you yeah yeah yeah you
go down the wrong path but what if
somebody's like detached the whole time
even when problems don't right you know
like that and we don't have a
relationship right that's what I mean
that's down that's what I'm saying so
they're not being detached all all the
time that's all right that's the answer
the question right so it's like you've
reiterated it for everyone yeah man
that's what I'm here for I think a lot
of times you know how guys will ask you
hey I want to learn you get to I want to
learn to mess people up think bro that's
not really what I do jiu-jitsu is having
the skills to pull up mess people up but
what you learn ultimately is you put
yourself in a position where you can
make that decision in time the mess I'm
gonna or not you know any self control
the address register
so that's really what most people that
start with the vision of I want to build
a mess people up most people continue
that that do continue on the journey of
jiu-jitsu arrive at a point where they
realize that they don't want to abuse
this power that they now yeah most
people yeah there's a small percentage
of people that don't that are bullies
yeah
bullies when they started they become
more effective bullying
yeah more fearful more fear in posing
bullies yeah which sucks yeah but you
get serious power that's why you're
gonna have some of it yeah agree but
compared to like a I don't own anything
where it's like striking based or
whatever it's like you it like I've said
this wrong I'm not gonna go deep in it
but you go from zero to ten when you
throw a strike that we are at ten no you
can't just throw a light one and be like
okay are we laid out you know kind of
thing they're not cool no you're not me
in the face wrinkled at all you brought
it to ten when you doctor might or not
he looks funny because like I see I see
my kids and and what you're talking
about can happen very easily when other
people are in the group with my kids I
mean yeah because they've been training
jiu-jitsu so even like against any
normal kid there's no factor yeah
like I see me know my son will be
wrestling around with some kid it's no
factor yeah and it's you know it's kind
of go yeah kind of cool yeah real cool
yeah I thank you you know my kids aren't
like jujitsu like there's kids out there
that are sick competitive jiu-jitsu all
the time yeah right that that's not what
I'm talking about like just knowing
jiu-jitsu a hundred percent correct yes
and but when I see kids doing jiu-jitsu
especially like I'm not saying in
necessarily even in a tournament I'm
just saying in jiu-jitsu in class living
at the beach or whatever when I see
probably Menace I wish I could have done
you to a little theater you know fun
that would be
yeah man it yeah make up for it now
right next question
Jocko I've been offered a job as a
deputy sheriff
a few months before the position is
actually open I really want slash need
to get into some jujitsu due to the
nature of the job the closest place to
me is over an hour drive away yeah hard
for you finances are an issue when it
comes to that kind of Drive plus fees to
attend my main question is how do you
feel about Gracie's online school that's
an option if I were to find others who
want to learn
would this be effective yes so here's
what you need to do get some maps you
can make maps you can get you can get a
piece of canvas from Home Depot or piece
of vinyl and string it between trees on
the ground
you just have mats you just made them
all over grass that works I've done it
I've trained on with there's a truck
called a six by in the military the big
giant like a truck sure and it has you
seen this in like your typical war movie
the truck with the canvas tarp over the
bemble I've taken that thing off and
that was my Mac on top of the truck no
no no taking it off the top of the fuck
you took that canvas turning that canvas
I put it on the ground guess what I got
now jujitsu math strong butter and
bourbon stakes in the ground we're good
to go to canvas but it's good to go so
you do that then you get on YouTube here
on YouTube you know Gracie Academy a
marcelo garcia online those are really
good i would actually start with youtube
just like get some basics down get some
fundamentals get you need two three four
friends if you got a friend that
wrestled get him in there i'll if you
got a friend that did you don't get him
in there and then you just start looking
at the moves and fighting each other and
trying to see what works and don't go
nuts on each other try and figure out
what works what doesn't work learn the
basic concepts and then maybe saturdays
maybe every other saturday maybe one
Saturday a month you drive an hour to
the school with your buddies you go in
there you say hey man we live up and
wherever an hour away from here if we
give you ten bucks go get on the mat you
know this weekend well just for just for
a couple hours can you look at what
we're doing maybe even say hey looking
before let's get a private we'll all
give you twenty bucks that's 80 bucks
you can make it an hour coach please so
then you get some detailed training and
that's going to give you a base you know
that's that I think your best option
yeah fully and these um online uh you
know academies and stuff yes essentially
what they're made for if you can't yeah
that's exactly atomy oh yeah if you
tomato guide me you go to Academy yeah
where that Academy is yeah yeah and I
think podcast number six we talked about
what to look for in a jiu-jitsu Academy
yeah so go back to podcast number six if
you're starting jiu-jitsu and you want
to find a good Academy go back to the
podcast number six
get in there yeah fully and I think to
start especially if you don't know dude
you to it all I think a lot of us
started you Jitsu with watching UFC 1 2
3 4 you know so we kind of after
watching that we kind of see okay I see
if your mouth is
you have mount that's good yeah if
you're on the bottom card if you know
see yeah I think I I didn't I knew what
jujitsu was so I didn't get to
experience trying to learn the basic
moves from seeing on your see so I'm
taking what you're telling me as factual
and it makes some sense but so did you
actually like compute this two positions
you were like okay that's regards you
must have watched in detail and well no
mister watch remember like okay that guy
was crazy that guy that's wearing that
white thing that white uniform look what
he's doing he's got his legs closed
round guys that's what you guys were
doing essentially but because even the
announcers weren't calling it guard back
then were they yes there is a guy who's
real nerdy guy and he was I was you see
- I wanna say and maybe even what I
forget which one was which but yeah he
knew and you could tell he was like kind
of prideful that you would train at
Orion or whatever but he got see you
know how he's gonna pull him in between
his guard like that's you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah but he knew and you know okay
he's going to mount and it was real
repetitive because he'd do the same
thing so yeah you you essentially if
you're paying attention you learn guard
that way you don't learn how to do an
armbar how did you know well when I
teach kids sometimes I'll just say you
want for like let's say a kid's been
training for a day so first day you want
to keep your legs around them right yeah
that's guard they don't even know what
they're doing and then you say the other
kid you want to get away from there or
get around their legs yeah and so they
just try and do it and that's a pretty
cool way to start things off very be
surprised at what kids will
instinctively do yeah I make things
happen there yeah and you even at the
muster you know how you explain it just
real quick like you're okay this is mild
is wide support as guard that's why it's
important that's really like the other
day added there was a new girl in there
her name's Sarah I remember that because
yeah I know someone else named Sarah but
anyway uh Adam it was time to roll Brown
say hey there's like Hayden you know
there's some new people here no day zero
days or whatever experience can you down
an old teacher something you know as a
rounded
because I didn't have a partner have
came in late whatever but so I went and
I did essentially that just for crash
course this is Mount this is guard this
is a side mount Rio and this is the
importance of each one and then this
literally takes five minutes
and so here's the importance of everyone
and then I do a little quiz at the end
so okay boom boom we fight it's like a
pasty we fight boom Baltazar what do you
want to be yeah and you know so it's
like a little quiz and boom right there
that five minutes you learn everything
that I learned from watching you see one
two three but it pours out of you and
we're studying them and you were trying
to figure it out but yeah you can learn
in five minutes for somebody Jonah do
exactly right if that's what they're
teaching you a lot of times people go in
on their first day and some some
academies they're dope they'll have an
introductory classes classes just kind
of that it's called introductory class
but if you're like hey it's my first day
let me see what I can learn then they'll
learn like some you know omoplata or
something and they're like way whoa I
don't know how this even makes sense to
me you know yeah but if you learn that
crash course or you know even put in the
Hostin that's why it's so cool you you
go over that and once I get dang this is
cool you can leave that and now you're
way better off they're not funny on the
rosters everyone has heard us talk about
jujitsu so they have this anticipation
of it being really cool and then when
they connect the dots between like okay
you learn the mount and then you learn
the guard and then you learn the sit up
sweep and when you're done with a set of
sweep here you're from the guard you're
back in the mount and people are like a
miracle a miracle
yeah man so there's the magic yeah and
it's essentially before the actual moves
like doing the moves it's just you have
to know what's important what's not like
if you mount on someone just by
happenstance you don't know what mount
is really important but if you wind up
on the mouth you're trying to punch the
guy I'm saying in the fight you're
trying to punch the guy in trans do
damage trying to win the fight but
punching the guy is not what you should
be focused on primarily it should be
keeping the maintain the pose yes
exactly right but no one's gonna
automatically know that it's not you
know you trying to beat up the guy I'm
on top I can punch them let me punch you
but no it's just one of the many
examples that Quest
chuckle my boss is incredibly
controlling an egomaniacal I was I like
him already
egomaniac contractor I have I've
attempted to use extreme ownership in
dealing with the people under me but my
boss has reprimanded me for leading he
has said he gets he gets to do all the
leading because he's the one in charge
quote-unquote and and his job title is
higher than mine that that happened to
me before by the way if I could continue
to try to lead my responsibilities will
be taken away if I step back into the
shadows I won't make an impact on the
people under me what should I do
so it's black and white yeah right in
his mind seems oh you can either step up
and lead and get fired or step in the
shadows and do nothing never suffer it's
not it's not that way right it's not
it's not black and white but and
actually start by putting your own ego
in check because you're calling someone
egomaniacal but you're your ego is being
being touched a little bit here yeah rub
the wrong way a little bit because you
want a lead and when you get told don't
lead you can't offend you yeah guess
what that is that's your ego so what you
need to do is maybe you like that you
like the feeling of being in charge
that's cool I like the feeling of being
charged yeah it feels good to me feels
normal to me when I'm not in charge I
don't like it I have to consciously
suppress it which is fine sometimes you
have to do that like right in this
situation here this guy's talking about
and what you need to suppress is you
need to not be so overt with your
leadership he shouldn't even be able to
sense that you're leading but you should
be leading you got to be under the radar
you got to be covert with what you're
doing and buzzes while you're doing that
you're massaging homeboys ego make him
feel good about it they can feel that he
is running things and because because
you can absolutely lead from the shadows
if your ego allows it
because a lot of times when we want when
we lead we want everyone to know that
was eating yeah I want everyone to know
that I'm in charge I want them to know
that I'm bland right that's really hard
when you're leading from the shadows a
lot of times not even the people that
you're leading recognize overtly that
you're leading think about that so the
people that are actually following you
don't even know that they're following
you mmm
they don't they don't consciously know
it maybe if they were to break down and
you give them like a hey who do you
think is actually giving you instruct
maybe well I think that might be
probably yet seems like a deco okay okay
but they don't like consciously think
about it so that's what you need you you
need to suppress your over leadership
not step on the boss's toes massages
leader massage is ego a little bit
because if you do get your response you
want to help right
well you want to be helpful you want to
lead these people in a great way if you
don't if you get your responsibilities
taken away or you get fired then you
can't help anyone anybody you're not
gonna help the team at all so you have
to be smart and you have to play the
game to win his confidence and his trust
so he does let you meet and what's going
to do that when he realizes that you're
not going to step on his toes that
you're gonna give him the credit because
he wants to credit he's an egomaniac
right he's controlling so that's kind of
what you need to do now this is the
weird thing and this came up with the
muster people don't want to hear me say
that people don't want to hear me say
that if I come up against a boss with a
big ego what you need to do is back down
people don't want to hear me say that
mmm
they want to hear me say if you come up
against someone with a big ego what you
do is you blow up - yeah and you show
them that they ain't got nothing on you
yeah go back down to the don't back down
to that guy with a big ego that's weak
you know - and what I said at the
monster I said I said listen cuz I could
see it I could see it people are like ah
yeah I guess Jocko isn't always as
hardcore as I thought he was going to
back down to somebody with a big ego you
know and I said guess what people this
is why you feel that way
if there was a machine gun matched on a
hill and there was a bad guy and then
he's killing a bunch of people shooting
that machine gun hmm and everyone in the
room wants to look at Jocko and say
Jacque was brave and Jacque was tough
and Jacque was gonna charge that machine
gun nest and take that guy out well
guess what a machine gun belt-fed weapon
in an elevated position bunkered in i'm
not going to take that guy out
I can't it's a heavily defended position
I can't do that so what Jocko does is
backs down I hide it I get behind cover
so I don't die once I've gotten behind
cover so I don't die
I look at EKKO when I say echo stay here
shoot some rounds that this guy
occasionally distract him I'm gonna
flank him so echo is going to keep
undercover himself he's gonna playing
some rounds up at the machine gun nest
while he's doing that coming to scurry
away like a little baby like a little
sneaky little squirrel yeah and I'm
gonna go around to the flank because the
machine gun isn't a bunker right so he
can't see out the sides I'm coming up
the side I'm gonna get right beside my
tossed grenade in there and kill him I'm
gonna take out the ego but I didn't do
it going head-on mmm so what happened is
people coming up up against this big ego
and they want to be the hero and they
want to be aggressive and they wanna
default aggressive jock who you say beat
you you you got a chapter in your book
default aggressive man I'm gonna be
default aggressive against that ego yeah
wrong answer
yeah the right answers in direct warfare
the right answers maneuver warfare the
right answers you flank these people and
by the way if I do charge that
machine-gun nest or I do attack that
guy's ego guess what I die or I get
fired and now I'm no good to anybody so
it's people have this this desire to be
the strong hero and you have to fight
that that's your ego that's my ego
charging machine gun nests I'm gonna go
do this on the man no I'm actually not
the man it's a machine gun
position I'm gonna die yeah you have to
be smart yeah like on that attack that
you go head-on don't attack the heavily
defended positions head-on period like
you said in training day you're for some
movie training day
no come on right you watched it anyway
he says the shit is chess not checkers
she's not the first person I've ever
said I know but it was dealt when he
said it in my opinion
nonetheless yes default aggressive isn't
default aggressive paid to head it's
default of a default aggressive in being
effective yes as I've ever really your
effective or ineffective at the end of
the day muster abeyance no I listened
lake knows what he's talking about like
that
mmm good choco is it that next question
yes how do you shift your mindset from
individual contributor to manager
growing a company from nothing to
something required being individual
contributor and getting a lot done with
a little but as we grow it's clear so
they need to hire people for specific
roles and accept the accept that I can't
do everything I'm very used to getting
stuff done and doing everything myself
and it feels a little weird trusting
someone else to do it how can I shift my
mindset to appreciate being a manager
over an individual contributor so
straight up out of the gate you are
actually failing as a leader by doing
what you're doing but I did by by
continuing to do things yourself getting
the weeds and not let people lead you're
actually failing as a leader and
therefore failing the team so number one
you have to watch out for that and you
know by the way that means the more time
that you spend in the weeds getting
stuff done yourself because you're so
perfect that's the last time that you're
thinking about strategy that's the last
time you're thinking about you know
what's going to happen tomorrow and
future operations and that's not good to
be in that situation so first of all you
need to build the trust with these
people you don't have to give a hundred
percent trust to someone out of the gate
if if I if we're a company
I hire you and I'm gonna have you doing
some task that doesn't mean I say hey
echo here's the task go do it and now
I'm just gonna walk away I don't even
know you
I don't know how well you can do the
task so I'm going to say hey echo here's
the task actually watch me do it okay
you've seen me do it now I'm gonna watch
you do it okay cool you seem to be doing
that pretty well I'm gonna come check on
you in two hours see how it's going come
back two hours next day I check you once
every five hours next day I check you in
the morning I check you once in the
afternoon next day I just check you at
lunchtime maybe two three four days
later I check you once every other day
pretty soon you're good to go and guess
what I'm doing I'm doing something else
doing something that I should be doing
I built the trust I confirm that you
know how to do it I you trust me because
now I trust you we're building some team
and some relationship so that's all good
so to the original point though I think
the way that you shift your mindset is
to recognize that micromanagement is
actually failure no progress is made
while you're micromanaging the longer
you are micromanaging someone the longer
it takes for them to develop as a human
being and as a useful person in your
organization every minute that you
micromanage someone is a minute of them
not thinking for themselves there's a
minute for them not taking ownership of
something so I'm micromanaging your task
you're not taking ownership of it if
you're not taking ownership of it we
know where that leads mmm so let people
learn let people lead and to not do that
is failing don't fail one time one of
you in Hawaii get your driver's license
at 15 Bing I don't know how what it is
not a long time ago obviously but I
learned to drive with my dad before that
you know when we're young we be getting
quite a dirt roads everywhere so he's
like hey you know and it started with
when we were young when we're young
young like seven eight years old we'd
sit on his lap so he'd do the shifting
and the gas and the brake and stuff like
that dirt roads we just do the steering
that's what it kind of started with then
after a while he's like okay now we're
just going to learn how to do this
you know it was a management stick shift
so he's like okay now you just learn how
to go right and now it's going shift
gears all on the dirt road whatever and
so I was like just turn 15 or maybe even
14 and he was like hey um like alright
let's go drive no usually it'd be like
we were going to the beach on the way
home hey let's take this dirt road you
can steer kind of thing but this was
actually like okay let's go drive so I'm
like alright but he popped he plops me
in the front seat and he goes all right
take us there we're going wherever we
were going down to the beach like all
right take us there like dang I don't a
bribe steered before I shipped the I
haven't done the whole thing all at once
but he was sitting right there you just
said take us there like don't I took
took him there whatever he didn't
critique much you know um but I got
there and he just kind of let it happen
he was the same kind of thing where
first he's checking my steering they
needs choices over time yeah years and I
hope and yeah after a while it's like
boy stuff and I he's still managing he's
right there he could slide his foot over
to the brake if he needed to I guess if
me - yes put his hand on the wheel steer
away from the oncoming truck if need be
yes and at the same time he's letting me
make little micro mistake I hit the kerb
a little bit yeah well you wanna you
know stick shift you do too much or yeah
well any let that happen because that's
my thing to figure out the feel cause
each car is different and it's cool
because that's actually good at one time
we were going on an operation my first
deployment to Iraq and we were driving a
far distances to cities we'd never been
through before and we've got turned
around in the city and we were I had a
far way to go to our objective it was a
kind of a high-profile operation and
work we stopped and I hear the call on
the radio like all stop and I say
something along lines of you know what's
up and you know the point man which is
the lead nav in the vehicles he comes up
where he's like just trying to get my
bearings a little stress
I walk up so I get out of my vehicle
just to mention this guy's one of my
bros and I walk up the vehicle and he's
in there and I could see he's he's
flustered mmm he's flustered and he's uh
you know um I don't say embarrassed but
he's flustered and now I'm there yeah
you don't I mean yes and do I think his
thoughts are Jacko's you know the shock
was gonna be mad or whatever yeah and I
I go up and he's he's cracked open the
door right I opened the door on Monday
and I go you know what's up man just in
the most mellow voice but I go hey
what's up man he goes I I don't know
where we are
I was like cool man we'll set security
let me know when you got it dialed and
he's like all right cool yeah and that's
what we did so and it took like you can
see his face like he just turned back
computer started working but when I
walked up to me know he could see Dan
was panicking because you know you got
we had a bunch of vehicles you know you
got seven vehicles with us and and
they're all driving around and I've done
two laps around the it is not fun and
there's and you know you make it through
and like pass the enemy one time you got
away with Julia now you went by them
three times
listen it's not cool and everyone in the
whole book book troupe is sitting there
and the vehicles going
hold on jackass is gonna run us by this
checkpoint again or I'll say again yeah
all of us so but yeah just went up hey
bro what's going on man I'm just trying
to where we're at okay
we're gonna set security let me know
when you got to figure it out good so
good man and that's yeah that's so good
on you because you know everyone is
stealing the strata like what you're
saying for like it was like dang where's
this guy leader hotel does another one
I'm sure everyone was feeling that then
it's like all right I got a kind of
detached from that feeling and go you
know yeah dang and and then you know I
got on the radio because that was a no I
just said I said the guy's name like hey
just getting it sorted out right now
where me rollin heared about a few
minutes when we know we're at I never
asked you know said security boom done
there was another time we got ambushed
on that same climate sir and I
is in vehicle number two and we're in a
big convoy and the the ambush pretty
much was aimed at the center and in the
back of the convoy so a bunch of
machine-gun fire a bunch of RPGs and
nothing really hit in fact nothing did
hit the RPGs went over us and and I was
I would never say much on the radio
right and the guy in the back vehicle
he's actually a platoon chief but I say
I didn't say much but clearly we just
got ambushed I mean it was a hassle but
I'm just you know fired explosions going
off and we pout we know we go through
that we continue on and the platoon
chief in the back he says something on
the radio something long lines of he's
like you know comes up with a music hey
jogo you know we just got hit with an
ambush back here and I got on the radio
knows like Roger and and you know it's
like it's it never knows okay I guess
we're all right yeah like all good all
good in the hood yeah you guys are crazy
I think he did me like that one day yes
in fact when I say I think I mean I
remember the time you did me okay so I
was I'm forgiving me right now you just
talked about an actual ambush actually
happened I'm talk about something way
less impactful just bear with at least
you're asking for forgiveness me I tell
every story it was actually this pod cat
we had recorded like a week or something
early cause like boom let me finish the
whole thing get it ready to get pushed
out all I need it was done all I had to
do is press the button to make it live
that's all I had to do and this was like
a week I think might even been two weeks
in advance
wow those were good old days yeah but um
and then the day came it was so done and
out of my mind the day came and I was
just like hey I don't know it's not on
my mind so long story short I I didn't
do it so yeah I didn't press publish is
writing it there anyway so I wake up in
the morning as you message well a buncha
Twitter posts right I understand that
but I got a text message I think there
might even be a phone call oh no no is a
phone call and a text message from you
this you know this is
is something you know I'm like I what
did you have to want what it was no I
had no idea I was like Oh something
obviously is not you know I get this
early in the morning by the way yeah you
know so I look at it um and so I listen
to the voice message first and it was
you all coming like hey how's it going
oh good morning okay so as he goes um
just to sort of let you know it's
Wednesday you know we have that but that
podcast we recorded that's you know
that's supposed to be going on right now
so whenever you can whenever you're
ready go ahead and post that but it
wasn't like all the Twitter folks were
where's the book you spoke with rookie
slacker yeah all that I'm gonna dr.
sissy whatever you ready it's all good
you know I I didn't know what happened
maybe you're under more stress thanks to
never know you got to think when you're
in a leadership position not that I'm
like the leader here but if you're in a
leadership position you don't know what
someone else is going through maybe you
had some technical issue and I'm like
gonna call you up be like well where's
that thing and now you freak out he
making or yeah I don't need to make it
any worse there's something going on
like you were sleeping that's it I
didn't want you know but you always
think about the perspective of the other
person that you're dealing with and you
don't want to escalate things yeah
that's not gonna help ya just
de-escalate hey man just wondering
what's up to speed you in anything for
me on the podcast maybe we need to
re-record it I really do let me know
I'll be over that's what we're here for
and like with two people shouting at
each other and you chime in so a strong
drowning and you're ready I got three
people trying to go yeah messing it up
anyway next question Jocko I'm not sure
I agree with your statements not to
pursue belts in jujitsu
it doesn't seem wrong to me to benchmark
success using a rise in rank as a
quantifiable measure of success as a
person is working to master their craft
any craft it's nice to have markers for
accomplishment and engagement I've built
why have belts if they're not to be
strived for or why have them right yeah
and that's actually a little
conversation I had that as soon as he
asked me this this is with Brandon no
Brandon
kicker Thea is he's been around like
since day one in in the game here and we
were going back and forth on something
he said he actually sent me this random
could he send me text about stuff you
know whatever we're doing some projects
and whatnot and he sent me this random
thing well I guess it's random to me it
was random to him maybe he just listened
to a podcast we were talking about this
pretty said you know hey I don't know
you know I don't know what agree this
stuff about belts yeah and so and by the
way Brandon is had a goal of doing a
hundred burpees in ten minutes
Brandon is in good shape he's an athlete
athletic dude and for some reason he
can't do a hundred burpees in ten
minutes I don't know where he's at right
now we are publicly calling him out yeah
to post his you know video video no cuts
no cuts
yeah or maybe didn't have to post the
whole thing I take his word for it cuz
he's owned it a bunch of times you'll
put like he'll do a hundred in oh no I
think what he's been doing he's been
doing ten minutes worth however many you
can do he gets like eighty four yeah so
and you'll post it like I did eighty
four geminate was that you can do tents
at the ten it has that one blue tenant
every thirty cent every minute or
something it have to be less because
actual burpees will take a certain
amount of time yeah yeah and I know that
though I'm telling you ten in a minute
is not that hard
yeah but plus your rest can in order be
pull-ups in a minute is hard to her yeah
but still a good measure
so just regular burpees but back to the
conversation sure I'm gonna try that put
this okay so Brandon hit me up and and
you know I understand belts you know and
it's good because we've said on here
like don't worry about valves don't
worry about the bells the bells are
gonna come I understand belts and I
understand trying to earn a rank and
that's cool but I'm telling you at some
point and I think this will happen to
everybody at some point Jiu Jitsu
becomes a lot more than just belts and
eventually the Jiu Jitsu itself
but completely bypasses what the belts
are and what the belts mean now I could
you could say back to me like well let's
get your black oh yeah and so that's why
you feel that way because of course they
don't matter of you you're already a
black belt you you know but this is the
fact is that that didn't happen to me a
black belt that happened to me at like
purple belt I think about midway of my
purple belt time I had no care
whatsoever of what bell color I was this
is literally zero and I just wanted to
get better I just wanted to know more I
just wanted to keep training and never
even thought about it after that and now
like even like degrees on your put on
your black belt like Pete I was talking
to Pete Roberts the other day
musical what degree are you he's a black
belt in the Bible he said what degree
are you and I was like I don't know I
don't know I got my black belt in 2005
what does that mean you know what I mean
like I don't have the tape on there with
how many degrees I am not but I don't
respect it yeah I just don't care for me
personally so and I think that this
isn't like he's like Brandon talked
about you know to master any class I
think it's the same with any craft that
you're trying to master yeah if you're
trying to master the craft hopefully and
eventually the craft itself becomes more
important than the rank that comes with
being skilled at the craft yeah that's
what I would hope for
that's what by the way that also makes
it a lot easier to keep pursuing because
I don't care I'm not sitting there going
I okay I hope you get a stripe on my
belt today no I don't care if I get a
stripe my books I want to go learn more
yeah and guess what's going to propel
you towards more stripes wanting to
learn more yeah wanting more stripes
does not propel you towards getting more
stripes what propels you towards getting
more stripes and getting advanced in any
craft is getting better at that craft so
focus on getting better at the craft yes
sir
the belts are going to come yes sir even
your belts going to come alright preach
it I'm not concerned with belt so we're
glad you're not that you got much in
your future
nonetheless yeah and I think that this
it's like a matter of perspective okay
first off you being a black belt and in
thinking that or whatever and like at us
easy it seems like that's obvious that
always easy for you to say because
you're a black belt but at the same time
doesn't kind of go along with that
detachment thing so hey I'm not in the
game there's no reason for me to be
striving for any belt right now so I can
be detached I'm not emotionally invested
in the whole situation I can look back
in and at the same time understand when
I came up me being focused on belts
would not have got me here yeah you know
like you have that clear vision ain't
that snatch its a natural thing to be
like a blue belt and I wish I could wear
that purple belt and everyone would know
me and respect me as a pro belt and I'll
become having some of the purple belts
right now yeah and bro up do you do the
side note I don't know if you know this
but it is you know the feeling of
wanting that purple belt really bad and
I just want that purple belt and your
skills from your premier instructor
standpoint don't match purple belt and
promotion time comes along and you're
okay is it to him I get my brand you
don't get that purple belt burn you know
how sad you're gonna be real so I've
known people that quit the gym straight
up because they didn't get built up
promoted on a certain day and you know
what is the day that's really sad it is
it sets on something bottom for sure
that's a side note but I guess sad was
even right word well it's sad for them
yes like because if you hear in that
zone where you should be getting your
purple belt at some time maybe this
promotion maybe next promotion maybe
some other promotion that means you're
dedicated Jitsu and now you're just
gonna walk away because you didn't get
belch yeah that's rough and like I said
like that state of mind can really
really gently lousy and then true story
and I've heard of people where they
didn't get their belt and then maybe
someone else did not maybe straight-up
other people did and it was there about
you know like they're mad super mad to
the point where their vocal about it I
kept that guy out why'd he get his belt
pocket open saying that so yeah it'll
Jam you up this the whole mindset one
thing you know I would say to those
people that might be thinking that way
for my perspective and for many jujitsu
instructors the the your your advancing
and your getting promoted
based on your potential not based on
your skill level to other people yes
your because you might be you might not
have a lot of potential and so you know
what hey man the guys you know he can't
train he's you know 68 years old and
he's been training for a year and a half
he's learned a lot of knowledge he's
here all the time I mean he can't tap
out any other blue belts we're giving
his blue belt because for potential of
him as a 68 year old man that never
worked out before now he's trained in
jiu-jitsu do that guy's a blue belt
yeah now the further you go up you know
black belt is a little bit more serious
uh so is brown so it's purple but I'm
saying you're getting judged against
yourself and that's an extreme example
by someone else by the way not by
yourself
you ain't judge by your instructor not
yourself yeah that's right that's right
so yeah man and that's the and that's an
important thing but what your to your
point everything that we're talking
about right now makes you Jitsu suck
right it makes you sit like it makes it
maybe it'll make you mad it'll make you
frustrated it'll make you and make it
political and this guy got it I didn't
know that's enough for me I just don't
like that stuff yeah you know don't even
like that stuff yeah when you're ready
your instructors gonna promote you yeah
until then keep training yeah and and by
the way also in your work skills when
you're ready to get promoted you'll get
promoted yeah and if you're not ready
you want or there's not an opening you
won't you know what you do to solve that
don't get frustrated don't get all crazy
don't blame the guy that did get
promoted don't undermine him know what
you do
keep kicking ass wait next time it'll be
your turn yep enjoy what you're doing
master your craft sir
don't let your craft become your master
yeah thing I liked it yes and that's
what happens right yeah you know that
the thing control you is it a you
controlling the thing instead of you
mastering it it's starting to master you
and getting your head bad but he does
make a good point
and here's the thing is that this is a
mix of perspective so we're um two are
clashing of perspectives we're
is like art you know as a person working
to master their craft any craft it's
nice to have markers for accomplishment
and engagement sister yeah and you know
what I actually texted back to him I'm
like hey man I know I'm not normal
yeah I'm not normal and all I need is a
rock and a hill yeah that's why I texted
70 last right but so so there are normal
people that need to have like I want a
goal I want to see I when I have a
connect point and that's okay yeah and
that's why I guess what there are belts
in jujitsu and you can't get your we
don't really give a lot of stripes out
at victory like me Jeff Glover rain
Lister Craig James I mean we'll give out
like occasional stripes you know for
various reasons but most the time it's
like no the guys ready for his next belt
right give it to him yeah and usually
starts that's a subtle thing in my
opinion like I've to do the stripes
don't reflect much compared to black
belts
nonetheless I mean yes cool and
different you like a more stressful belt
right I was Miss Peale what you think
you know and you know what to do degrade
what you're saying and what Brandon
saying you know when we do lot of
stripes and a lot of different colored
belts kids right and that'll be the
point yet has a grown-ass adults Brandon
no as a grown man you should be like um
cheer to learn yeah they're gonna happen
well to me what he's saying doesn't
clash with what you're saying in my
opinion no matter thing with Brandon is
Brandon is you know I don't know him
that well but you know we go back and
forth a lot he's a guy that's like
metric driven you know like I'm gonna
get right I'm gonna get this never get
that and that's awesome that's what
makes him successful and what he does
and craft that he has mastered very
successful but he likes to have those
yeah those measurements Yannick to have
metrics to go off and say look I just
crushed this this goal boom done yeah so
well yeah and so with Delta's going to
be a little bit different just like with
promotions and you know based on the
skill so you if he says it's nice to
have markers and you know think it is
nice of course after after when you got
your black belt for you to say I don't
care the fact that I got this black belt
I don't care about that
at all I don't know if I would believe I
don't know your you'd be correct yeah
you'd be correct I was I'm stoked yeah
no it's just a matter of when driving
for me what kind of surprised me do like
I wasn't expecting it right which should
tell you something yes I wasn't in there
like tonight's plug gonna be big right
no I like showed up at the gym and
trained or whatever yeah and then all
son it was special ceremony time yeah
not the black belt
yeah and I was stoked for sure yeah I
was soaked but you know what's funny is
like at the team like people people like
I don't know who heard about it but
people that hey man I heard you got your
black belt I was like yeah yeah but I
didn't tell anyone
right I wasn't like hey everyone I got
my black belt yeah yeah you know right
my guilt you know what you know what
belt I cared the most about was my
purple belt
yeah when I got my purple belt I was
super pumped yeah at that time it was a
big deal yeah getting your purple belt
I'm a purple belt from Fabio Santos
yeah I I wasn't giving away that purple
belt either nah rock in the dirt
you had earned that thing yeah and you
know what with and I don't know cuz
obviously I wasn't there at that time
but I think it's always gonna be like
that we if you get a purple book that's
a big deal you don't know it seemed
definitely a big deal
because there's just so many people now
doing jiu-jitsu no purple belt purple
belt is a legitimate when you're a
purple belt yeah you will not lose in a
fight to a normal person no in my
opinion Oh could you get caught with a
paunch yeah sure yeah but a normal you
know you've got a very high high
percentage of winning a fight against a
normal person if you are a purple belt
in jujitsu yeah a good purple vote yeah
meaning not someone that just like got a
purple belt for the reason right right
you're a real program Jitsu I mean a
purple belt you're rolling like when I
roll the purple ball it's a good roll
you know there's a good roll it's not
like oh this guy's just a purple ball
blue belt most blue belts you don't have
to worry about much of anything yeah
when you're at a higher level yes yes
yeah I mean you're not worrying where
you're rolling with most results right
I'm worried when I roll it to everybody
yeah so no no no no worried right now
I'm just
- yeah I I dig it is not on your
training it is acid actual but I'm not
saying you're disrespectful to a blue
belt but but realistically you know that
chances are there's no possible way for
them to submit you a very small change
yeah yeah the personal battle skill
levels don't matter although there's not
a triangle on you or something proposed
grab your arm somewhere oh yeah uh yeah
I have no one you rolled with no later
he tied me out oh well yeah not I mean
not like delet but yeah like within the
last year yeah he straightened my arm
out real far yeah I had to go into level
9 defense oh yeah and see oh I was just
full and he surprised me that was the
thing you know we're rolling and all of
a sudden and he's a purple belt that's
there you have it
there's a classic example in this in the
defend no I'm gonna give her me I'm
gonna give him a nickname right now good
Noah give you good Andy very handsome by
the way he's better than all this I'll
let you judge that one but you better
than a typical purple belt though you
don't really yeah yeah but nonetheless
to your point that's exactly your point
though if you're purple about your yes
you're not you don't have many holes no
maybe some timing things maybe some you
know whatever good good yeah use a
classic example yeah
knows a good purple but watch out but
yeah you don't pursue I know what hello
ask me all the time when do I get my
brown belt no I'm just kidding a lot of
weird one no doesn't care yeah Jesus
ever dude that's like hey I'll do sit
around tap everyone out maybe one day
look at me about maybe they won't know I
care
yeah you crushing it yeah and that's how
and he'll rapping out echo Charles no ro
what's up did you give him your brown
belt once you got tapped out by him I
want it actually you know what I do when
you get tapped out by a lower belt it's
like guess what digital works they
should be able to wear your belt for the
day for this to your life yourself no
jujitsu works if you do jujitsu move
against me I'm gonna tap out to it yeah
like that's the way it works and you
know I might try the defense but the
jujitsu works mister I mean we just saw
Roger Gracie Hodge your Gracie against
boots Shh yeah and people were a little
bit freaked out I was like yeah jujitsu
works yeah you know get that choke on
we catcher bootjet is it animal savage
yes but get that geek collar sonken
choke you got you got Hadji Gracie X
amount of times world champion can you
imagine his grip strength are you rolled
with it yes yeah
grip strength his grip strength it was
really good but what and I'm not to go
into a whole thing about Dodgers game
but he has this thing where this is
weird if you don't know the depths of
jiu-jitsu but he has this feeling that
he has all bases covered so they're not
necessarily his game isn't to out-hustle
you is not to outspeed you and it's not
out strength you for sure but it's like
he it's like he has this whole base like
all his bases in the jujitsu situation
they're all covered yeah so he'll do
this thing that and he was trying to do
them but chef like you know vishesh is
really really good he'll grab one sleeve
with the opposite hand will grab the
elbow and original from a close guard
when I don't pull and they'll just wind
up on your back and there's nothing you
can do about it
all your little defensive you've got
discovered there no problem and it's
just this thing that it just it's like
this eventualities that you have no
defense for that's how it feels his
holding yeah so yet I mean it's crazy
that he was able to bring that same game
up to someone like buchecha they're in
favor judges a beast
yeah do you think yeah it's just crazy
so yeah that self nonetheless back to
the point don't pursue the belts that's
not the pursuit the pursuit is getting
better the belt will come when the belt
comes to the to UM Brandon's point when
the belt comes that is nice and to me
when you get your belt from your
instructor not from yourself yeah when
you get well they're gonna beat yourself
but if you're the guy who's getting mad
yeah if you're the guy that's getting
mad and because you think you should
have got your belt and you're thinking
you're getting your belt from yourself
that's what you're thinking Oh in your
head yes yes exactly right so to forget
I'm ready yeah I'm ready exactly round
up to you not up to you you can tap out
all the black belts it's still not up to
you
it's up to instructor anyway when you
get your purple belt brown belt black
belt
yeah that's Bo I would say this happens
more times than not if you're a blue
belt you're rolling you're getting good
you're learning a lot when you get a
but purple belt that's going to empower
you so much to be like now my standard
just mentally is higher now I'm a purple
belt now they're like minimum standard
right now well a purple belt is full-on
in the game
yeah yeah right sure you you can't
really be super casual and get a purple
bow right I'm doing like a catcher or
not yeah I'm saying it is empowering and
it is you that you're gonna have a lot
of pride with that well I wouldn't say
empowering I would say it puts you it
raises the bar on you
yeah like once you're wearing a purple
ball you can't be you know you now
you're like I can't tap to these blue
belts anymore you might but I'm saying
yes same thing to me tomato tomahto
raises the bar yeah would you say it
raises your standards
yeah rolling like my own state basically
exactly okay yeah like dollar is raised
yeah I gotta represent yes you know all
this stuff it's like it comes with a
sense of pride yes it's a it's a deal
and that's why also when you're a blue
belt enjoy being a blue belt yeah take
more risks you can get tapped out
doesn't matter you let it flow yeah
hundred percent well yeah when you get
that belt yeah be happy be prideful
posted on Facebook and you know thank
your training partners alike stuff but
don't just pursue the belt man it'll Jam
you like 10 next question I'm a 24 year
old machinist I work CNC machines do
setups and order tooling most of the
people I work with have worked here for
over 15 years
the owner my company wants to make me
the shop manager and honestly I'm not
too tore up about it I feel like the
older guys who've been around won't want
to take scheduling and manufacturing
advice from a young guy I have good
relationships with all the shop guys but
I'm worried about stepping into this
role so soon only been with the company
for three years
any advice okay your boss isn't asking
you to do this job if you're not ready
for it that's that's number one and the
fact that you don't think you're ready
is a good sign I've said this before
because it means that you're humble so
you feel like that that's good that's
probably one of the reasons why you're
doing well and by one of the reasons
that your boss thinks you're ready for
the job is because you're humble so
that's good but you also have to
remember that being humble has to be
balanced dichotomy of leadership with
confidence
and it was a little bit of aggression so
there's a reason that you're getting
asked to do this job and the boss needs
you to step up now just because you
become the manager the boss doesn't mean
yet you have to start bossing people
around right it actually means that you
should remain humble that you should
take input from them that you can still
take advice from them as opposed to just
giving them advice all those things are
fine and I just got asked this question
the other day young construction
business and a kid we were in a big
meeting with a with a bunch of
leadership foremen two engineers all in
the same room bunch of great guys from a
great company and one of the young
engineers raised his hand and said you
know I'm young and I am going to be in
charge of these guys you know I'm not
sure I'm comfortable with these guys
have been doing it for a lot longer what
can I do to you know gain their respect
and I said okay who in this room knows
more than that engineer back there about
construction all these salty
construction Foreman's raised their hand
and I said who you know who's gonna
think that this guy's got the best idea
raise your hands all the hands go down
and I said so this is what you're
dealing with
buddy I said now let me ask another
question the group group if this kid
comes in and says I know how to do this
better than you listen to me
and do it my way who's going to have
respect for him raise your hand no hands
go up if this young kid comes in and
says hey I'm an engineer I've been
educated but I haven't been doing this
for long can you give me some
recommendations on how we do this so we
can do the best job possible who's gonna
have respect for everyone raises their
hand so there you have it you you don't
have to know everything as a leader no
one expects you know everything
especially as a young leader that's okay
and actually when you admit that you
actually gain respect when you ask for
people as input you actually gain
respect people get the paranoid feeling
that if they don't know something
they're gonna be seen as weak it's not
true so you can just step up
the position still be humble still take
advice now this doesn't mean that you're
a pushover right that doesn't mean that
you just listen to what everyone says
you don't make any decisions no it
actually means that you show respect to
their experience and when it comes time
to make a decision you get the best
input and then you make a decision and
you explain your decision and if your
decision is wrong you admit it if it's
not wrong you push forward so that's to
need you you're getting asked to be put
in this position for a reason so do it
get some it seems like common Lenya down
I'm stepping in a new role for sure
everyone asked that question yeah I
answered it again there you go for
everyone's benefit but my own yeah I
learned from it every time well that's
the ethos right go in humble yeah be
open-minded think advice yes yes yes
don't have to know everything yes three
days ago
our neighbor young girl what my
daughter's friends
12 years old which comes over there
messing around there swimming she grabs
my daughter's jump rope and she's
jumping room she does the cross you know
you join you cross cross over whatever
also over here yeah so he does that and
man I used to jump rope back in the day
but I never really could do the council
first legislation nonetheless so she
jump roping and jumping rope and I'm
like hey do that cross the crossover
thing again she does it she's doing you
know she's 12 years old Utah I'm like
dang I never could do that she's like
well you just got to do it like this
until it so I'm like okay I grab the
rope and I try and the ropes do small so
I go grab my rope yeah I got a jump rope
um why told my daughter grab it so she
grabs it and this is like a kind of like
one of those pro speed ropes you know so
it's like gonna so if I make a mistake
on this rope is gonna hurt I didn't have
any shoes on I was barefoot homestyle
Hawaiian self for sure 100% and then so
I go for it I'm dumb or I can jump rope
still pretty good right now still I've
done in a while and she goes okay so
right here at the top you know you you
cross you this is where you want to
cross at the top of try Oh hits my foot
painful and she's like no you got doing
okay no okay no no never shoulder pain
to the kids good
I try not to anyway so I was like okay
boom fail
she's like no more at the top you know
it'll it'll just whatever so I'm like
okay I do it and it took me four times
on my fourth time I did it for the first
time in my life by the way the crossover
with the painful speed rope some you
know some mental fortitude right there
thrown err so hardcore I did it you
should have seen Brett you should have
seen the look on her and my daughter's
face they were like oh like it was you
know like I just got my purple belt yes
nonetheless so boom what do we have
right there the situation this is what I
took from it too we have a situation a
full-grown athletic arguably person
learning to do something that's really
not that easy obviously if I've never
done it in my life learning to do
something that takes a fair amount of
skill from a 12 year old girl in real
time and you know what I did to boot
gave her the credit
I said dang you are the the best you
have here one of the muster yes yes
exactly right
so that's the think your self of the
moral of your story which was a long
story
yeah yeah be humble you can learn from
anybody yes and when you do and from
someone give him the ground pin it boom
that's what I did see I said that in 13
seconds
I know brow but I'm just saying it was
impactful and it reminded me of that
story anyway next question chuckle just
checked out podcast 21 with Tim Kennedy
awesome raises a big time question
though you and Tim agreed that cops who
make controversial decision slash
mistakes do so simply because they're
not trained well enough that begs the
question how much does the environment
someone trains and impact their decision
making how much tactical decision making
is innate versus learned could killing
the ideology that that the insurgents
buy into be better than killing
insurgents or can they simply not be
reasoned with at any level
there have been terrorists who flee
their organizations and start new
peaceful lives in other locations
okay yes so the first part of the
question yes you trained how you fight
and the more you train the more you
reprogram your instincts so that's
important you're reprogramming your
instincts when you train and you get
better instincts so that's what you do
and and now when cops make mistakes
oftentimes it's because of their lack of
training sometimes they make a mistake
that is a mistake that got made you know
it's a mistake that's all it is and
they've been trained well and they still
make a mistake I'm gonna tell you the
percentage of mistakes go down
dramatically the more that you train and
the more realistically trained and the
more often you train you're going to get
better no doubt about it but that's like
an instinct your training your instinct
so that's the one thing this this idea
that we could just attack an ideology of
terrorists and then have some of them
convert that'd be a wonderful thing that
you attack the ideology and then some of
them become peaceful productive members
of society and if we did like a
full-court press to try and make this
happen we might be able to convert let's
say we were really successful we'll be
able to convert five or ten percent a
year okay so that's great then you have
to remember that the enemy is also out
there converting people right probably
at at least equal rate maybe even a
little bit higher so we still end up
losing the fight because to break even
is to lose because they're still out
there doing what they're do the keep
down and in the meantime by the way
they're still gaining territory or
causing terror so it's not a good
situation now the example that I use all
the time obviously our Nazi Germany and
Imperial Japan both of those groups were
like the current day jihadists they were
looking to take over the world and if we
just tried to kill their ideas with our
ideas we would be speaking German right
now because we would not
we couldn't have changed their ideas
fast enough and and by the way they were
playing a different game if we were
playing the game of let's say exchange
ideas the enemy is playing a different
game so for instance if someone is
trying to assault you and you're a
pacifist and so you decide that you're
going to try and convince them of the
virtues of non-violence through through
debate and the Socratic method and
critical analysis and the use of various
rhetorical devices and that's what
you're going to do and you might be the
best debater in the entire world but
none of those things are going to stop
that assaulter from punching you in the
face he's playing a different game and
once you're on the ground he's going to
start kicking you he's a violent person
now maybe if you were to stable a slow
and how long enough to try and reason
with him he's not playing that game
though he's there to attack you there to
stab you so your ideas aren't going to
defeat his ideas you don't have the
opportunity to do that he's not playing
debate so you have to know how to fight
you have to understand the violence and
you have to be prepared to use it and if
you can if you can debate and you can
win that's awesome that's awesome but if
it doesn't work you need to be prepared
to use violence as it's needed and
that's the same thing on a larger scale
obviously we we can do everything we can
to try and help snuff out this extremist
ideology let's prop up reformist as much
as we can let's try and bring economic
opportunities to these impoverished and
deprived regions so that they're less
likely to come under the psychological
grips of a death cult but at the same
time that we're doing those procedures
let's attack their strongest a factories
of hate let's go after their centers of
gravity and let's snuff out and destroy
those individuals that clearly have no
hope of reform and exist only to spread
this
cancer of hate and violence and terror
and death and if we attack on both those
fronts hopefully one day where we can
live in a world where we can solve
problems not with physical force but
with our intellectual power and that
would be great and unfortunately I don't
think that day will ever come because
there's always going to be someone out
there that's going to attack you
regardless of your debating skills next
question
yeah long question here yeah my general
question is is there a point where it's
no longer physically realistic to train
jiu-jitsu big Jiu Jitsu today on the
podcast yeah GG it's a heavy jujitsu day
yeah yeah I'm okay actually I noticed we
were going back to jiu-jitsu a lot yeah
yeah absolutely
we took some questions that weren't
about jiu-jitsu that we turned a mini
jujitsu questions to you after sometimes
yeah I'm a former competitive athlete
but have experienced various injuries
that I still work through on a daily
basis I really want to get into
jiu-jitsu but my only hesitations are my
lingering injuries I don't know anyone
who trained so I don't have any sense of
how much is too much when it comes to
physical limitations and injuries I'm
sure you must have had injuries over the
years that hindered your training were
you able to modify your training to
accommodate them them although I have no
experience I greatly respect the martial
arts and the last thing that I would
want to do is waste the instructor or
other students time by not being able to
fully participate and or holding up the
class I hope this question can benefit
other podcast listeners who may be
wondering the same thing however to give
you a give you full detail in reference
to the question I'm 26 and the injuries
I'm dealing with are it's the list left
knee that I need to work on daily to
maintain full range of motion on my
third ACL meaning he had searched for
three times
well yeah he's had three actually said
he had heart surgery seven times but
that's his third ACL oh you feel so - oh
yeah third ligament been put in there
yeah could they replace the ligament
yeah it doesn't grow back and it doesn't
heal so they got to give you a cadaver
or they either give you your own from
your hip or your yeah from here yeah or
hamstring or poor hamstring and they put
that in there or they give you a cadaver
one yeah I had that and they sail back
in the cadaver my own from my hamstring
monka I've had saige at seven surgery
well I haven't this is back to the
question I've had seven surgeries most
recent being a femoral osteotomy in
cadaver meniscus transplant there you go
I'm told one more major injury to the
joint and I'm looking at a full knee
replacement hang at 26 to left shoulder
dislocated several times torn ligament
cartilage and labrum don't plan on
having the surgery anytime soon and hist
and a history of multiple concussions I
powerlift jog metcon tail yeah regularly
but all cutting sports but all cutting
sports are pretty much out of the
question
I think oh betting on sports yeah yeah I
got you know if he says but all cutting
sports are pretentious meaning cutting
you know you know when you caught on the
field all cutting gotcha okay cutting
less cutting right I'm pretty sure
that's what he means okay yeah at any
minute yeah Carlos people jog he can do
mad cause we can't cut gotcha
track okay either way I get I got you
sports are pretty much other question if
jiu-jitsu isn't feasible do you
recommend any other martial art that
would better fit my situation just
getting tired of only trying trying to
stay physically fit and would rather
incorporate the beneficial skill into my
training or is this all in my head and I
should stop worrying and just get after
it
thank you for any advice you can offer a
podcast thank you for your service right
awesome so I kind of broke these out was
when these let me break these out of
here so his first general question is
there a point where is no longer
physically realistic strange get to the
answer that really is yes but you can
also train you to in a wide variety of
levels of intensity
oh very wide you could theoretically
just go and learn the techniques yeah
you could just learn the techniques and
never actually roll
someone and if you couldn't do anything
at all
that would in my opinion I would still
do that yeah just to just to no one
understand it I would still do that yeah
would you agree yes and now what you
have to be watch out for is that you're
going to want to try them yeah you're
gonna want to try them in someone real
and that's just that's what you're going
to need want to do now you know like I
said you can do it from just from just
learning the techniques only to all the
way to competing in jiu-jitsu and like I
said you got to watch out that you if
you can only learn them and maybe you
can real like maybe you can find you can
roll with flight people or you can go
with really good brown belts that are
light and that that used tell them you
know up front hey I got injuries I'm not
here to for an ego trip I just want to
try the moves you better freaking keep
your ego in check though which is what's
so hard because you're gonna thank
skinny you finally I get out of this and
then you end up getting hurt ya can't
let that happen
so don't let your ego get in the way you
might not want if you have all those
serious injuries like it sounds like you
have you may not want to roll with
anybody for a long time until you really
truly understand jujitsu
so that's question number one yes you
can learn it without much risk actually
very limited risk if you're just looking
to learn the techniques you could learn
it with very limited risk now the next
question have I had injuries over the
years and was I able to modify my
training to accommodate them absolutely
yeah I've had ankle you know sprained
ankles high sprains all that stuff and
when that happens you see me training my
bottom game a bunch because I'm not
going to be on top I hurt my back one
time really bad and I couldn't do an
oppa this is how the blue belt couldn't
do an oompa couldn't do it
guess what I did elbow escaped my elbow
escape got good because I could not do
it open I've had my MCL 80% tear get
some guess what no factor put on I
couldn't train for like a couple weeks
but then I put on one of those hinged
metal braces strap that thing on tight
could I do closed guard no could I do a
triangle on someone no did I
be careful yes did I train absolutely uh
my neck I had neck surgery and you know
my neck now doesn't hurt yeah go I and
my whole game is kind of based
fundamentally around protecting my neck
so I don't do certain moves that I used
to do that were that are high-risk neck
moves just right like yeah there's just
certain moves that I just don't do
anymore because it's high-risk neck move
and I don't to put my neck and adjust
into jeopardy so yes you do go through
things now occasionally like I just got
through a a few weeks where I had three
simultaneous injuries and it was a
broken knuckle uh some kind of a knee
issue and I had a gaping cut on my toe
my big toe riddled half the skin off the
bottom a toe and so I said to myself
okay I'll just tape up my entire body
and still train no I didn't say that
I said you know what this is you know my
body telling me you know one injury you
can get through two injuries okay wait a
second but when I finally tore my toe
open I was like okay maybe it's time to
take like some time away from the map so
I didn't train for a few weeks right pry
the longest I haven't trained in it
since I can't remember but that's three
injuries stacked on top of one another
and now I'm just thinking myself you got
to be kidding they let them all heal and
that's what I did so that's that the
next sort of question was if jujitsu
isn't feasible do you recommend any
other martial arts that would be better
fit your situation I think you can
always go in jujitsu I think you learned
a box you could learn more how you've
got to be careful I carefully tied up
knee surgeries you got it I would say
little and no sparring since you've had
concussions and like I said in all those
cases you're going to learn the boxing
like wow I think I want to try this out
man looks pretty easy that's barring
right I'm gonna get in there don't
you've already have concussions you
can't you got to keep your ego in check
and then the last part of the question
was or is this all in my head and I
should just stop worrying and get after
it
look we all have got to know our
limitations you got to also know that
sometimes you're putting limitations on
yourself that are too tight and you also
got to realize that sometimes you can
push yourself too hard and overdo it end
up in a really rough spot where you got
a permanent injury like you know right
MA to my knee is not fully healed and so
instead of doing nine rounds Abdul Jitsu
I did like four yesterday five yesterday
five today you know not and and avoiding
a couple positions right you know that's
what I'm doing yeah that's okay I can't
go in there it can have the big ego
maybe I'm gonna be on top right now no
you can't do it and the more impactful
Partizan can have the big eagle if like
somebody comes up with okay let's roll
Brent but okay I'll roll with you cuz I
don't want to look like a loss yeah yeah
no no actually I got an injured knee can
roll right now which I hate saying yeah
I can see why I'm saying that yeah I
just by saying that I despise it but I
know that you know I gotta heal up Emma
part of the game yeah that's not me to
go and check remember Jerry Loudoun
never yes so he had jammed up me and I
thought of him you know well um you know
reading this guy's question yeah um same
age maybe I don't agree might have been
a little bit older maybe ask me like 32
or something yeah so jammed up nice but
you know he gets a guy so he comes in
and what he always do is he'd be like
hey let's he'd grab me because I've
known him long time Roman too
he he'd be like hey let's he what he
called it you want to play
meaning like we're just rolling you know
just like how you said like how you uh
like how I warm up with Andy yet again
exactly right yes he's really good for
that to you right now Dean is not good
for that yeah so the whole roadie Dean
will literally say to me hey let's just
get warmed up and then he'll get it
across side and smash me for four
minutes and 38 seconds yeah and yes and
we did torture me yeah so I do not do
warm-up rounds with Dean I mean we
didn't even go to help no one around
here it obviously Dean does that on
purpose
Oh fighter it's like can I do that you
when we do that Dean
two advantages number one I'm not warm
and that means there's no sweat yet so
he's so there's there's like just
friction and he can just secure
positions and it sucks and and
psychologically we both know and the
other the other advantage that he has is
he's fresh because the deeper we go into
deep waters the better I'm doing because
I'm in better condition than him I did
it man but he has those two advantages
out of the gate so he's gonna make you
pay so flooded you could tell though
it's not like a little thing oh you say
there's a 20-something year thing with
Dean hey man I dig it and that's
probably going to continue to you know
till you guys are back and I got an
incident yesterday yeah man and so
yesterday happened you know hey what
happened talk about it no I already
talked I don't know words were exchanged
loudly in the gym anyway Jerry is really
good with that where this is a guy in
this guy situation more or less me wise
anyway theorem and um I think he was
even both his knees yeah so you know so
you can do that and you can get like a
good movement good rolling without that
that impact you know when every once in
a while you got to turn up the heat or
whatever on a guy because that comes
from ego yeah it's more of like this
competitive kind of spirit of rolling
jujitsu that's kind of what it is so if
you can avoid that you got actively
avoid it and still get that movement if
you can find the right person and you
can go and just go you can learn you can
get more or less live situation but you
just can't be like Jeff is that little
fight in the fight you're gonna let that
go okay good great but yeah you can
learn for sure you can learn yeah don't
do takedown if you got a knee situation
don't do they'll take down take down
situation that's gonna be hard all right
okay last question and you know this
this last question it's not really a
question well it look I get a lot of
awesome emails and I get emails from
people that have completely turned
their lives around they've they've lost
weight if they need to lose weight or
they've gained weight because they
needed a gain weight or they've gotten
promoted or they've become a better
parent or they become a better spouse or
they become a better kid yeah and I get
emails from people that have quit their
addictions or they've or they've
overcome their fear and I say what I get
letters and packages and notes about all
this kind of stuff and it's awesome I
get I get people send me books for the
podcast and pictures and drawings and
and and military memorabilia or unit
patches and coins from your police
departments and fire departments and
military units it's just it's awesome
and and I'm I'm so thankful for all that
feedback and it it drives me that
feedback that I get drives me to work
hard and keep pushing to do this to the
best of my ability and try and get
better at it but you know I hear from
people that have used the podcast and
the discipline and the the mindset of
looking at things that are problematic
as being good I hear from people that
have used those things to overcome you
know dark patches yeah in their lives
you know whether it's depression or
anxiety or even like full-fledged
despair and again when you hear from
people that are turned that corner
that's just incredibly rewarding to know
that there's you know there's people out
there that are really changing for the
better and turning their lives from
negative to positive it's unbelievably
rewarding but I also get some other
emails and I get some other messages
from people that haven't been able to
dig out of that hole
to overcome that that despair I hear
from people sometimes that feel there's
nowhere nowhere else to go there's no
way out and they don't have any more
options and they are considering taking
the only way out that they can see and
that is they want to take their own life
and to anybody out there that's in that
place you know I don't really know what
exactly to tell you but I can kind of
tell you what I think I think no I think
no I think don't save that last bullet
for yourself don't save it for yourself
you lock and load that last bullet and
you shoot it at your enemy and when
you're out of bullets
get out your knife and attack with that
and if you lose your knife you grab your
enemy by the throat and you keep
fighting then you keep fighting and you
keep fighting and you keep fighting no
matter what and you never quit we never
never quit and if you feel like your
life is in a place where you can't get
any lower and you don't think you can
find any way out good because that means
the ultimate challenge is ahead of you
it means you can only go up and it also
means that things are going to be tough
things are going to be tougher than
anything you can imagine but that storm
that you're in from from your
perspective it seems like that storm is
enveloping the whole world but I'm
telling you it is not the storm that
you're in it is hard to see out of that
storm it's hard to see past it it seems
like the storm it seems like the storm
is everything
but the storm is not everything and it
won't last forever you can get out of
the storm and you will get out of the
storm and when you get out you're gonna
see the Sun again but right now you're
being tried
you're being forged you're being tested
by fire and by pain that's the test
don't fail the test don't fail the test
don't give in don't quit don't ever quit
fight on fight through the storm fight
through the pain and come out the other
side stronger and tougher and better a
fighter
a survivor a winner victorious and free
from that storm free from the darkness
free
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight
so echo Charles speaking of being
stronger and being better yeah maybe you
could tell us some ways to make
ourselves a little stronger and a little
better yeah and at the same time sure
possibly support this podcast if they
want to yes under no obligation to
support yourself well I think as even
being your but I'm just saying as far as
the message here it's up to you but if
you do want to what pursue whatever you
want to pursue your participation is
required does that make sense no okay
anyway so I'm gonna talk about on it so
good fitness gear good stuff I just got
some fulvic minerals mm socket for my
way nonetheless they got some good stuff
for any uh area of getting after it that
you need to or that you want
supplementation with so remember that
jump rope story I told him right that
was an on it jump rope there you go yeah
pro speed rope I think it's called it's
like brother there's a lot of
technological advances in jumpers no
back you know we're you know yeah if I
just go for me yeah just Peter leather
hide yeah or what was mine like a wrote
is straight up a rope with a handle here
and another handle at the end that's it
this sounds like a swivel as a thing it
has a police system on it maybe I don't
know what it's called made out of this
stuff it's like yeah it's good it's good
anyway yeah that jumper was gum also
kettlebells mm-hm
solid solid heavy heavy as you varying
weight right about one for my daughter
the what's the what is it the little
monkey howler
so it's going I think the 18 pounds or
something like that she can lift it up
she can't swing it she's for everything
about you dead lifting it yeah but for
me be surprised man little kids by a
natural instinct to perform exactly
right because they're trying to find the
perfect balance oh I have no choice they
do off got they're just gonna fall down
my son eleven months old now start
walking at straight up it's kinda early
err than my other like nine almost ten
months I know that more right yeah yeah
you can be also I know that makes you
give you an unbelievable a feature
separating it recruited right now that
everybody says that's what they say
everybody's kid is the best kid in the
world
yeah that's what everybody saying and by
no means is that my message here but the
message is you watch him do a squat to
pick something out like dang that's good
form so my daughter she forced picks up
the the kettlebell little holler and I'm
like the first time like she I don't
know she should be picking it up she
doesn't know what she did picks it up is
perfect for deadlift for my likes when
my youngest daughter was like six or
seven I had her deadlifting and could
have had her - no didn't know and I
pushed her too hard and she was dead
lifting and she like our back oh how old
like six or seven she was just doing
like double body weight but it was with
kettlebells
and so you're not going that low so it
makes it a little bit easier so I
thought yes there's only dead lifting
and my son was in there - I think my
other daughter we were all just getting
a screw realtor sir and you know so Mike
you can do this you can do this and
we're a skating weights and going
heavier and heavier and finally we get
to like a pretty big weight I forget
what it was it might have been might
have been maybe the 32 kilogram or
something like comfort so she lifts it
and like right as she gets almost the
top she gets the look on her face and
like like moves sharp and then and then
she like started to tear up to drop she
drop and she put it back down and she
started to tear up and she's like I
think something happened to me back
daddy and I was like oh god I am the
worst father ever
yes think yourself don't go with a heavy
kettlebells for the kids or heavy
deadlifting but they're not ready for it
yeah I'll go and record straight up and
say don't
by kettlebells for your kids your
program that you got sorted out form in
one therefore we're 11 months or
whatever wait till they're six let's do
it
I bought the kettlebell because when I
go out there just a water one my
daughter that daughter deadlifting and
like posted at one time people are all
pumped yes good is pretty soon and it's
dope to see in a pin yeah but man you
can't get crazy with that I think if I'm
lifting my kettlebells they're cool
there's a werewolf wands and you know
all the stuff my daughter's out there
she's cruising she's watching she's like
you know she obviously let me try let me
try and she she can't negate yeah I
wanted to pick up that werewolf it
weighs 62 pounds one of them ocean you
don't let her I don't know that what I
don't push her to put that up no she'll
grab it and there is she don't pick it
up no it's too heavy for and books but
she just wanted you like dad
yeah that's how it is so you gotta the
howler just as a little gift you know
hey you got your own credible you how
empowering that is I'm not saying that
now now let's lift kettlebells girl
you're only four now you're on the pro
it's not that it's for her to have her
own little kettlebell and beat you know
it's like a cohesive thing you know no
it's cool just like she likes to do
pull-ups but not really she's not a
pull-up routine she reads warrior kid I
read it to her and she sees me doing
pull-up she's like my turn I want to do
pull-ups now when she's able to get on
her own program or be more in a position
to facilitate a program imposed upon her
as the case may be
not too early by the way she'll be
familiar with pull-ups she'll know the
value of bullets plus dad has pulled up
so it's obviously cool yeah you know and
she's going to be down she's going to be
kind of set for life in regards to pull
ups kettlebells whatever so I like it so
back where can you get those oh the
kettle put ya on it , or the jump rope
or the jumpers jump rope still
nonetheless don't I don't think actually
I do think that those designer
kettlebells those are kind of like the
that's the kind of the prima donna one
actually knows every time yeah that's
the wrong way okay with it now I'm okay
with it they're dope
they're good yeah you like them they're
not like the hardcore dusty yeah
cannonballs with handled you know
artistic other ones I have yeah yeah the
ones I have yeah they're not like that I
got all this the design ones but they
are cool if you walk into a gym you know
you go to the gym you're wherever and
there's a bunch of kettlebells right and
you're looking for a certain weight and
let's say there's the werewolf ones and
then there's the regular ones which ones
you can eat me is this a serious
question or just like a basic question
everyone both what do you think I would
use werewolf ones probably see that's
where you know well nonetheless I think
they're cool and go ahead check them out
they're on it calm slash Jocko that's
where you get it support yourself really
and it supports this podcast also if
you're into these books we didn't read
any books but I made like a few books
today yeah met in hackworth books yeah
right I mentioned dick winters Brooks
where can you find those books well
ultimately you get from Amazon like
everything else but if you want to go
through the list of specific books a
little website jockle podcast comm
section on the top or menu item on the
top boom click you to the page with all
the books by episode by the way actually
I don't think of extreme ownership on
there but nonetheless click through
there that's kind of jacked up well
actually it's row to the right
yeah so that's the thing extreme
ownership is so we may look Harvard it
in the podcast correct so it's not going
to be on the list of books covered in a
podcast because the section is called
books from the episodes unless maybe all
of life on it will do extreme ownership
yeah very cool that'd be like layers
because you wrote the book you're
wearing like all the sitting next life
you do the audiobook and now you're
doing about so it's like a thing anyway
go do that go to Jack podcast calm boom
choose whatever book or books that you
want click through there to get them
boom gotcha that's a good way to import
you know very good it's like gum and
it's what take one one second two
seconds and big support small action big
reaction just saying mmm
you're so you know what I'm saying you
understand also good which support is to
subscribe that's on iTunes teacher
Google Play and all these other
testing providing platforms not to
mention you to if you like the video
format you know see what chocolate looks
like if you don't know already uh you
know I guess you can see what I look
like which I'm not saying - look at me -
look at me , Darius if you don't know
what EKKO looks like go look on YouTube
yeah you can clear what it looks like
because he doesn't look like what you
think he looks like apparently yeah
parently evident I've known him too long
to understand the what he appears to be
via his voice but apparently he doesn't
sound like what he looks like so yeah I
guess I want to check that out yeah I
guess they don't match my look in my
voice yeah apparently not but you know I
live in a world where we're judged on
the content of our character and the
contents of our hearts so I look doesn't
matter quite as much as one might think
but if you are less interested in seeing
that could you - while you're at it
subscribe that's a good way to support
plus we're going to we do add other
videos that are shorter in forum we do
have the video version podcast whole
thing to our throughout however long and
EKKO is going to post a video of I think
it's the most I've last captured on the
human history yeah I was laughing that's
something that was not in the podcast we
were recording wasn't in the podcast I
laughed really hard it was pre podcast
yeah pre podcast record sesh sure and
that happened so I'm looking forward to
seeing that one you better get up before
this thing comes out anyway yeah anyway
that's a good way to support subscribe
YouTube other xx small excerpts on there
anywhere from one minute to 12 minutes
lives the exception uses between one and
three minutes little lessons that you
can kind of strategy one that thinks 12
minutes is next Serb I don't know I
don't think that's right technically it
is yeah I guess it is but technically
let's make them three minutes okay you
get it you should you should put more
effort into them and and and cut them
down like the real critical parts that's
what I think okay thank you for letting
them out on the Africana like that at
all no no no I'll good thank you rare
your acid no I'm gonna try flank hey you
know what I think there's good
but you think they big over better
favorite you can a little bit for the
reason yeah and the long ones you the
pro with this stuff I'm just kind of
agree see you got got about that
whatever you need doing the man but
nonetheless that's a good way to support
so for you can make the extra 17 minutes
long
yeah but maybe there's seventeen minutes
of complete beauty
yeah on a bright value yes exactly right
singer uh-oh time also Jocko has a store
it's called chocolate or chocolate or
calm that's the website so anyway on
there there's what t-shirts travel mugs
some bumper stickers on there some
patches these are velcro patches you can
interchange them they're cool they wound
up being pretty cool yeah I agree yeah
guys that deployed yeah representing
weird angles overseas yeah it's so cool
to UM it it's it's weird cuz you know
like you always say like we're sitting
in this room you know and sure we got
some patches out there but to see them
likable but you know they posted on me
and they'll send it to you know tagging
stuff like that just see I'm like dang
guys are rolling around straight-up
representing it's like it's weird it's
it's we're in a good way yeah no it's
awesome it's yeah it's super awesome to
see so yeah did some stuff on there heck
just go chuckles Oh calm that's the
website and hey if you like what you see
if you like an item get it I know good
way to support also on your journey we
all no matter what y'all will ever say
we all hit moments of weakness and just
like if you're going to max bench I know
I said this you promise say it again
because it holds true if you're going to
go 1 rep max or even to write max
whatever on bench
what about 3 arcs 3 red max is where it
starts to get a little bit more safe I
think in my opinion but let's say to rep
max you're gonna have someone there to
spot you just in case you fully intend
to get those two reps fully but when
you're pushing it it's wise to have a
spot
for some reason maybe you didn't eat
your you know a good whatever maybe
didn't get enough sleep I don't know but
you could hit a little roadblock a
little moment of weakness you have that
spot there boom gets you through get to
that last inch on your rep or whatever
keeps you on your path this is the real
world version of this is called
psychological warfare what that is it's
an album with tracks chocolate tracks
and for any situation you might find
yourself in that you have a moment of
weakness like getting up in the morning
or skipping your workout when you
intended to work out or slacking on your
diet Chuck will be there with a track
that will help you through it
it's called psychological warfare jakka
willing to a search iTunes Amazon music
other mp3 providing what do you call it
outlets like outlets yeah to get a real
good on cool also you know we've got we
got kind of a kind of a big announcement
coming which we haven't really had any
big announcements right I'm not a big I
don't know what I'm not a big
announcement kind of guy right plus so I
guess I'm not going to do this whole
thing with the big announcement thing I
will I will say this visit ok no no just
will say I'm not gonna hold back
look this what's going on after many
months of due diligence and
conversations and relationship building
and growing understanding we are
actually joining forces with a company
called origin origin Brazilian Jujitsu
in Maine now this actually occurred
believe it or not due to this podcast
this podcast I was doing a Facebook live
I said something about this was months
ago said something about origin today if
you want to get Aggie from origin they
make them in America they're well
crafted special material woven
up in Maine they're cool check them out
and Sarah Armstrong no sir I'm sorry of
course they do
she motivated God after it and put me in
touch with this guy P Roberts who's the
founder and owner of origin and you know
I knew about him that's why I was
talking about him on the Facebook live
because I because I had seen him and I'd
known that like a like a possessed
psychopath he wanted to make G's America
so he went and found looms to weave
material with that all that stuff and he
and the thing is is he was basically
alone with his team on his quest to make
this happen but the cool thing is he's
not alone anymore mm-hmm he has a
partner now exactly as partners now me
you and and really all of us to help out
to get in the game with what we're doing
now and and just say no origin like I
said it's not some brand that's throwing
some graphics onto a t-shirt right
that's not well that's not what's going
on there you have a legitimate movement
for lack of a better word of a guy that
is up there and what we're trying to do
is we read rebirth manufacturing in
America so that's it started with these
um that's definitely a huge focus but
we're going to make everything we're
going to build the best gear in the
world not just for jiu-jitsu but for
everything you do in life we're going to
make the best gear for being on the
warpath
that's what we're going to do so we'll
come out with a bunch of details that's
the baby now intimate that one's going
to come I just made it so hey you know
what in the meantime check out origin
mein kampf orgy's for rash guards for
whatever else you might need and if you
want to see what this is all about by
the way if you want to see what we're
going to do come up to the camp that
what happens to G to camp up in Maine
echo is going to be there I'm going to
be there a bunch of black belts are
going to be there we're going to be
getting after it or cruising or both
it's August 20th through the 27th two
sessions are going to be there echo and
I are going to be there the last day of
the first session and the first day of
the second session so that's when we're
going to be up there and people been
asking what level of jujitsu do you need
to be you can be any level if you've
never done it before
let's go come we'll teach you we'll give
you the base I will give you the basic
that thing that echo talked about
earlier but so if you've never done it
come learn it'll be the best
introduction you're ever going to get in
your life quite frankly just to come and
train immersion for either four days or
seven days that's a good way to start
learning a language get immerse in it
and and by the way also if you're a
black belt or a brown belt or a purple
belt and you want to come up with just
trained hardcore the bunch of good dudes
come on up so that's that also this is
cool on the 23rd of August so in the
middle of that camp there is we are
opening opening a new factory 20,000
square feet of American manufacturing in
Farmington Maine come on up it's
actually open to the public so come on
up hang out we're going to be there you
know doing what we do cruising checking
out and it's going to be it's like
pretty historical in my mind this
merging of bad badassness
come into fruition after many months
behind the scenes so yeah come and join
us on that day the 23rd even if you're
not
the camp come on up uh you know also
we're gonna have at the camp choco white
tea it get we have plenty of it so you
if you if you're not coming camping you
want chocolatey you can go get it on
Amazon if you're if you're sick and
tired of deadlifting less than eight
thousand pounds order some immediately
you also weigh the warrior kid and thank
you for all this awesome feedback that
everyone's been giving me of kids
getting stronger and faster and smarter
and better that's awesome
so if you have a kid or you know a kid
get him or her this book and by the way
if you're wondering well store your kids
that for girls believe me well what is
your girl think of it that's a job
upstanding doesn't matter so they need
it we all need it so get one for
yourself as as well there's lessons for
everybody in there from Uncle Jake sure
the other one got another book coming
out discipline equals freedom Field
Manual now if you want a feel-good book
if you want a book that's going to fill
you with a bunch of fantasies don't get
this book book is not for you
this book is real this book is going to
hit you hard and if you don't want to
get hit hard
then don't order it if you want to be
coddled don't get this book if you want
to be lied to you don't get this book
but if you want the truth
and if you want to get stronger faster
smarter and better then guess go ahead
and order this book order it from your
local bookstore go in to them and say
you know can i order this book and when
you get it in can you just put it in the
get after it's section for me so I can
find it
so this clinicals freedom Field Manual
order it online Barnes and Nobles Amazon
your local bookstore put the word out of
course you can also get extreme
ownership owner
ship is a keyword there and I recommend
you own it get that book own it yourself
and get it your team this copies as well
so that you can go out and annihilate
your enemy or your competitor
whoever's bothering you we also have a
salon front leadership consulting no one
else can do what we do and I'm saying
that right now and the reason I'm saying
that now because we've been doing it
long enough and I've seen what other
people do from a leadership perspective
and consulting no one else can do we do
so if you need leadership alignment so
your team can win you got me Lafe JP
Dave to our company don't book us
through a speaker's agent don't book us
through our online book agent go to a
tional on front comm or Gmail info and
echelon front comm and finally the
muster the next monster September 14th
and 15th in San Diego this is kind of
crazy we've already sold more than half
the tickets so this is absolutely going
to sell out just like it sold out the
first time in San Diego just like it
sold out in New York City just like it
sold out in Austin Texas don't get left
out in the cold get registered extreme
ownership calm come and come and get it
and while you're waiting for the
immersion camp or while you're waiting
for the muster we're not hard to find
because we're rolling on the interwebs
kind of hard actually next Jahi
something wrong Twitter the Instagram
and that faci boy
echo is a tackle Charles and I am at
Jocko willing and finally thanks to
everyone that makes this podcast
possible first and foremost our military
who keeps us free to create and grow and
live the way we want to live thanks to
you all for holding the line and thanks
also to police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics and other first
responders thank you all for making this
podcast possible by keeping us safe here
on the homefront so thanks to you all as
well and finally to everyone else out
there whether you're going through good
times or bad times whether you're
winning the game or you're making it
come back whether you're building a
house or a load or a bridge or a piece
of software whether you're assembling a
car or assembling a meeting or if you're
in a diner pulling a cup of coffee for
someone that's about to go out and pour
concrete whether you're sowing seeds in
a field or sowing the stitches into Agee
no matter what you're doing and what you
come up against fight hard do it with
everything you've got and no matter what
never quit
and always always keep getting after it
so until next time
this is echo and Jocko out